İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 14 Ekim 2024 Pazartesi günü 31. ders günümüz saat 19.31 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin değerli arkadaşlar.
Nerede kaldığımızı şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Templetler konusunda ilerliyorduk.
Önce templatlerle ilgili genel bilgi verdik. Tekrar etmeyeceğim.
Ondan sonra fonksiyon şablonlarıyla ilgili konuşmaya başladık.
İngilizce karşılığıyla Function Templates.
Fonksiyon şablonlarında Template Argument Deduction'dan bahsettik.
Fonksiyon şablonlarının overload edilmesinden bahsettik.
Kısmen Partial Ordering Rules denilen kural setinden bahsettik.
En son yanlış hatırlamıyorsam kaldığımız yer arkadaşlar.
Tabi en önemli konu başlığı Template Argument Deduction'dı fonksiyonlarla ilgili.
Eksplicit template argümanlarından bahsettik.
Birkaç arkadaşımın sorusu var.
Bana özelliğinden sordular.
Onlara da cevap vereceğim bu derste.
Arkadaşlar şimdi bu templatler konusunda terminoloji biraz ağır ve çoğunlukla da programçılar profesyonel rizeyde de pek dikkat etmiyorlar.
Yani terimler birbirine benziyor ve terimleri birbiriyle karıştırıyorlar.
Şimdi o zaman ben geçen dersten aklınızda kaldım diye birkaç soru sorayım.
Derleyicinin bir template koddan kullanılacak kodu yani C++ kodunu örneğin bir fonksiyonun tanımı kodunu bir sınıfın tanımı kodunu oluşturmasına ne deniyordu?
Yani sürecin kendisine deniyor.
Derleyicinin kodu yazmasından bahsediyorum.
Buna template'i instantiate etmek deniyor.
Hayır.
Specialization oluşan ürünün ismi.
Tabii onu san.
Yani derleyici template'i instantiate ettiğinde, template instantiation yaptığında,
yani bu da demek ki template'ten kodu yazdığında oluşan ürün, product, o template'in bir specialization'ı.
Yani örneğin şöyle bir template olsa void, punk, t, yani kodu yazmıyorum.
E şimdi derleyici bu fonksiyon şablonundan şöyle bir fonksiyon yazsa, işte parametrenin ismi, kod vesaire, bu şimdi bildiğimiz bir fonksiyon.
Ama bu fonksiyonu biz yazmadık.
Derleyici template'ten oluşturdu.
Dolayısıyla bu fonksiyondan bahsederken, oraya geri dönelim.
Bu fonksiyonu nasıl niteliyoruz?
Diyoruz ki fonk template'inin ptemplit parametresi yerine int tür argümanının kullanılmasıyla oluşturulan specialization.
Ama işte derleyicinin bu kodu yazmasına template'i instantiate etmesi deniyor.
Ürüne pekala template instance da denebilirdi.
Instantiation instance.
Fakat öyle demek yerine specialization deniyor.
Anlaştık mı bu konuda?
Evet, derleyici template'i instantiate ederek template specialization'ı oluşturuyor.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi template specialization'ı oluşturmak, yani template'i instantiate etmek iki farklı biçimde olabiliyor.
Biri implicit.
Biz şimdiye kadar hep implicit'ten bahsettik.
Diğeri explicit.
Implicit adeta şu demek, derleyicinin eski politikacı tabiriyle durumdan vazife çıkartarak instantiation'ı yapması.
Yani örneğin yine şöyle bir fonksiyon şablonu olsun.
Örneğin bari mantıklı bir şey koyalım.
Get max.
Hemen p türünden x, t türünden y.
Şöyle bir kod olduğunu düşünelim.
Return x büyük y.
Turner operator x y.
Şimdi bu fonksiyon şablonunun kendisi, örneğin ben bu fonksiyon şablonundan oluşturulacak fonksiyona şöyle bir çağrı yaparsam,
efendim get max, sadece örnek olsun diye söylüyorum.
Yoksa sabitle çağrımın bir anlamı yok.
20.10.
Derleyici burada bu fonksiyona çağrı yapıldığı için, bu da bir fonksiyon şablonu olduğu için,
önce argument deduction yapacak, sonra substitution, ona da ayrıca değineceğiz, dediğimiz süreci yürütecek.
Yani template parametresine karşılık gelen template argümanını fonksiyonun içinde yerine koyacak.
Burada bir hata oluşması durumuyla ilgili kullanılan tekniklere, belki duymuşsunuzdur,
SPINEI deniyor, meşhur akronim.
Substitution failure is not an error.
O da önümüzdeki derslerden birinde konumuz olacak.
İşte nihayetinde derleyici burada template'i instansiyat ediyor.
Derleyicinin template'i burada instansiyat etmesi için arkadaşlar ben bir talimat vermiyorum.
Ama bir de ilerleyen yine saatlerde diyelim ve böyle diyorum ama zamanını kestiremediğim için,
explicit instantiation var.
Explicit instantiation, derleyiciye fiilen siz bir template'ten instantiation'ı yapması için talimat veriyorsunuz.
Arkadaşlar, o belki çok sık kullanılan bir syntax olmadığı için şimdiye kadar görmemiş olabilirsiniz.
Şöyle bir template anahtar sözcüğüyle başlıyor.
Efendim işte diyorsunuz ki, getmax'ın geri dönüşlerini de yazalım.
Bu specialization'ı fiilen instansiyat et.
Ama şimdi konumuz bu değil.
Ama böyle bir şey var.
Henüz bizim görmediğimiz.
Buna ne deniyor?
Explicit template instantiation.
Bu da önemli bir konu.
Yani instantiation, ileri kursda tabii çok daha detaylı anlatıyorum.
Bu da geniş bir konu.
Yani derleyici hangi noktada bu instantiation'ı yapıyor?
Implicit mi?
Explicit mi?
O zaman şöyle terim tarafına bir dönecek olursak,
template instantiation.
Derleyicinin template konudan template specialization'ı oluşturması.
Bu da implicit olarak karşımıza çıkabiliyor.
Ki biz geçen dersteki örneklerin hepsi implicit instantiation'dı.
Ama bir daha az önceki sentaksı sadece şu anda aklınızda tutmanıza gerek yok göstermek için örnek olsun diye verdim.
O ise explicit specialization.
Implicit specialization ve explicit, özür dilerim, instantiation.
Her ikisini de ileride biraz daha konuşmamız gerekiyor arkadaşlar.
Şimdi devam edelim.
Ha, şunlar başka terimler.
Bir template için arkadaşlar explicit specialization oluşturmak.
Çok önemli bir konu.
Henüz bunu da görmedik.
Partial specialization oluşturmak.
Bu henüz görmedim size.
Şimdi bunun dışında bir template'i kullanırken derleyicinin template'i instantiiyet edebilmesi için template argümanı ya da argümanlarının ne olduğunu anlaması gerekiyor.
Bu kaç yolla mümkündü?
Üç yolla mümkündü.
Makro düzeyde biraz konuşalım.
Tekrar mikro düzeye geri döneceğiz.
Bir, kave neydi?
Deduction.
Fonksiyon şablonlarında var.
Model C++'a kadar.
C++ 17'ye kadar.
Class template'ler de yoktu.
C++ 17 ile class template'lere de eklendi.
Örnekler verdi.
İki, explicit.
Bakın birden fazla yerde explicit sözcüğü geçiyor.
Bravo Cengiz Han Bey.
Eksplicit template argümanı.
Yani,
template isminden sonra açısal parantezi yazıp,
template argümanlarının birini ya da birden fazlasını açıkça yazmak.
Eksplicit template argümanı.
Ve üçüncüsü de,
Bravo,
default template argümanı.
Deduction'ı büyük ölçüde gördük.
Fakat sınıf şablonlarına geçtiğimizde,
C++ 17 standartıyla yapılan eklemelere geldiğimizde,
daha önce olmayan,
C++ 17 ile gelen en önemli özelliklerden bir tanesi,
Class template argümanı dedakşınla da tanışacağız.
Şimdi hem bazı arkadaşlarımın sorusuna cevap olsun diye arkadaşlar,
hem de bu geçen ders öğrendiklerimizin bir kısmını tekrar etmek için,
şu deduction ile ilgili bir iki noktaya daha değinmek istiyorum.
Arkadaşlar şimdi fonksiyon şablonlarında,
function templatelerde,
deduction,
normalde argümanlardan parametre değişkenine aktarım yoluyla anlaşılıyordu.
Onu geçen derste gördük.
Ama bakın,
deduction'ın yapıldığı başka bağlamlar da var.
Mesela bunlardan bizi özellikle ilgilendirecek olan bir tanesi,
fonksiyon pointerları.
Mesela,
şöyle bir fonksiyon olsaydı,
H,
U,
efendim,
H,
X,
U,
Y.
Bu arada,
bu fonksiyon şablonunun bildirimi,
fonksiyon şablonunun bildiriminde,
arkadaşlar,
fonksiyonun tanımı olmak zorunda değil.
Bu sadece bir bildirim.
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
bakınız,
şimdi normalde,
hepinizin artık bildiği gibi,
örneğin ben bu fonksiyonu,
böyle çağırırsam,
T türünün karşılığı kullanılacak template argümanı olarak,
int türü,
type parametre için,
U için de,
double türünü kullanacak değil mi?
Int ve double.
Burada deduction yapıyor.
Eğer ben,
explicit template argümanı kullansaydım,
mesela bir nedenden dolayı,
böyle yazsaydım,
artık,
T için çıkarım yapmayacaktı,
onu long olarak alacaktı.
Ama,
double için,
yine,
çıkarım yapacaktı.
Ama örneğin,
şöyle çağrı yapsaydım,
double için de,
çıkarım yapmayacaktı.
İşte,
boy explicit template argümanı,
burada gördüğümüz gibi,
deduction mekanizması var.
Ama bakın,
fonksiyon çağrısı yapmadan,
şimdi,
int,
yıldız,
pp,
efendim,
long,
ve double,
int ve double,
eşittir,
bu.
Bakın,
burada da bir çıkarım oluyor.
Şimdi,
arkadaşlarımın,
bazılarının,
function pointers konusunda,
eksiği olabilir,
kendileri de söylemişti,
o eksiği kapatacaklardı.
Burada,
bildiğiniz gibi,
pp bir function pointer,
geri dönüş değeri,
türü int,
parametreleri int double olan,
bir fonksiyonun,
adresini tutacak.
Yukarıdaki,
bu template,
fonksiyon template'in,
ismiyle,
ihtiyar verdiğim için,
derleyince,
burada da bir,
çıkarım oluyor.
Gördüğünüz gibi,
burada da oradan,
bir fonksiyon çağrısı yok.
Ama yine,
çıkarım yapılan,
kontekstlerden,
birindeyiz değil mi?
bir not daha,
bu işte,
çıkarımın yapıldığı,
fonksiyon çağrısı dışında,
bağlamlar olabileceğini,
göstermek için bir örnek.
Arkadaşlar,
aynı parametre,
için,
void türü de,
bir template argümanı olabilir.
Yani,
void'un bir tür olduğunu,
unutmayın.
Ve C++'da,
void türü,
C'ye göre,
çok daha sık kullanılıyor.
Bir örnek vereyim.
Mesela şöyle bir,
fonksiyon şablonu olsaydı,
template typename,
T,
bu arada,
typename ile class arasında,
bu kontekste bir farklılık olmadığını,
bir kez daha hatırlatalım.
Örneğin,
T,
ne olsun,
U,
T,
Yıldız.
Benim bir void pointerım olsa,
void yıldız,
VPTR,
void yıldız türünü,
C'den herkesin bildiğini,
varsayıyorum.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi ben bu fonksiyonu,
VPTR ile çağrı yaptığım zaman,
buradaki,
matching,
hatta pattern matching,
nasıl yapılıyor?
E,
fonksiyonun parametre değişkenine,
VPTR'nin aktarılması için,
parametre değişkeninin,
void yıldız olması gerekiyor,
pointer to void olması gerekiyor,
bu durumda,
T'nin ne olması gerekiyor?
Bu durumda da,
T'nin void olması gerekiyor,
bravo ya.
şimdi,
bu ne demek?
O zaman böyle bir fonksiyon çağrısı yapıldığında,
buradan oluşturulacak,
specialization'a,
T türü void olacak.
Dolayısıyla,
bu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri olmayacak.
Fonksiyonun parametresi,
void yıldız olacak.
Hatta,
hatta,
izleyin,
ben burada T'yi de,
void türü karşılığı,
tabii ki,
kullanabilirim.
mesela biraz,
şöyle zorlamak için,
şansımızı,
T yıldız,
FP,
double,
böyle bir,
function pointer,
konumlayalım.
Bu,
T türü void olacaksa,
bu durumda,
FP de,
aslında,
parametresi double olan,
geri dönüş değeri olmayan,
bir fonksiyon adresi tutmaya aday değil mi?
mesela,
void,
bar,
double,
ve,
burada,
diyelim ki,
tabii böyle bir kodu yazacağım için değil,
kuralları göstermek için.
Bar fonksiyonun adresini,
bu,
function pointer'a,
yerel function pointer'a,
atadığımızda,
arkadaşlar,
evet,
şuraya da,
en azından,
null pointer olsun diye,
evet,
bakın,
herhangi bir şekli,
bir sentaks hatası yok.
Şimdi,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
fonksiyonu düşünün,
yani,
specialization'ı düşünün,
bunun,
void specialization'ı,
dolayısıyla,
burada,
void olacak,
fonksiyonun parametresi,
void yıldızı olacak,
buradaki,
FP de,
T türü,
karşılığı kullanacak,
template argümanı,
void yıldız,
void türü olduğu için,
böyle bir,
function pointer olacak.
Şimdi,
o zaman,
kaldığımız yere,
geri dönebiliriz,
bir iki soru daha var,
onları da,
geri geldiğinde,
cevaplayacağım.
Arkadaşlar,
fonksiyon şablonlarında,
en son şuraya gelmiştik,
geri dönüş,
değeri,
türü.
Önce,
oradan oraya,
daldan dal atlıyoruz,
kusura bakmayın ama,
böyle daha,
bence iyi oluyor,
daha,
ne diyelim,
eğlenceli oluyor,
çok formal gitmeye göre.
Arkadaşlar,
C++20'ye,
şimdiye kadar,
çok fazla değinmedim,
bundan sonra,
daha çok değineceğim.
Bakın şimdi,
C++20'de,
20 standartından,
bahsediyorum,
template'lere ilişkin,
general programlamaya ilişkin,
çoğunluğunu,
bundan sonraki derslerde,
göreceğimiz,
devrimci,
revolutionary,
İngilizcesi,
neler oldu,
eklemeler oldu.
Bunlardan,
gerçekten,
en güzel,
eklemelerden biri,
bu ders ayrıntılı,
anlatmayacak olsam da,
İngilizce,
abbreviated,
template,
syntax,
dediğimiz,
syntax.
Abbreviated,
ne demek?
Kısaltılmış,
değil mi?
Türkçe'ye birebir çevirirsek,
kısaltılmış,
template syntaxı.
Bakın şimdi,
böyle bir,
template yazmak yerine,
arkadaşlar,
hatta şuraya,
özellikle,
şeyleri koydu yazalım.
Bu bir,
fonksiyon şablonu,
değil mi?
Bunun template kısmını,
hiç yazmıyoruz.
Ben,
template'lere giriş yaptığımda,
belki bazı dikkatli arkadaşlarım,
hatırlayacaklar,
demiştim ki,
ne template'i olursa olsun,
template bildirimi ya da tanımı,
template anahtar sözcüğüyle başlıyor demiştim.
Ama burada,
bir rezerv koydum.
C++20 ile dedim,
bu da değişti.
şimdi bakın,
bakın,
burada,
T yerine,
otoki word'ünü kullanıyorum.
Bu,
C++20'den önce olan bir özellik değildi.
Arkadaşlar,
soru,
bu bir fonksiyon şablonu mu?
Cevap,
evet.
Yani,
template sözcüğünün,
hiç olmamasına bakmayın.
Bu sonuçta bir,
fonksiyon şablonu.
Yani,
böyle yazmakla,
şöyle tek satır haline getireyim ki,
daha kolay takip edin.
Ne aynı anlamda?
Sanki biz,
burada bir,
tam parametresi,
bildirmişiz,
ve fonksiyonun,
tam bir parametresi de,
bu türden.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Yukarıdaki ile,
aşağıdakinde,
kullanılan sentaks farklı,
ama sonuçta,
her iki setemle.
Şimdi,
bu,
C++20 ile gelen bu özellik,
bir kere,
yazım kolaylığı sağlıyor.
Arkadaşlar,
evet,
bu bir yazım kolaylığı sağlıyor.
Yalnız burada bir şeye dikkat.
bu konuyu çok daha ayrıntılı incelemek gerekiyor.
Ben ilerisi C++ kursunda çok ayrıntılı anlatıyorum.
Ama şimdi biraz değinmek istiyorum müsaadenizle.
Bakınız,
şöyle bir kod yazarsak,
T türünden X,
T türünden Y,
bunun karşılığı şu değil.
Bunun karşılığı şu değil.
Boyd,
funk,
oto X,
oto Y değil.
Neden?
E çünkü böyle yaparsanız,
X'de,
Y'de,
farklı template parametreleri türünden.
Yani,
bu aslında,
aşağıdaki funk,
bizim,
kısaltılmamış template sentaksında,
neyin karşılığı,
sanki,
şöyle yazmışız gibi.
Takip edebiliyor musunuz?
Alttakinden bahsediyorum.
Evet.
Şimdi,
templateler,
baya böyle bir pratik hale geldi.
Herkesin kullanabileceği hale geldi.
Mesela,
şöyle bile yazabiliyorsunuz,
düşünebiliyor musunuz?
oto funk,
oto X,
oto Y.
Bu bir template mi?
Template.
Fonksiyon çablonu mu?
Fonksiyon çablonu.
Fonksiyonun,
iki tane template parametresi var.
Birinci parametre,
birinci fonksiyon parametresi,
birinci template parametresi türünden,
ikinci fonksiyon parametresi,
ikinci template parametresi türünden.
Fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri,
işte bugün,
biraz daha bu konuda ilerleyeceğiz.
Auto Return Type.
Yani oto,
burada kullanılan oto,
auto Return Type.
Ama burada kullanılan otolar,
bunlar arkadaşlar,
kısaltılmış template sentaksı.
Şimdi burada,
tabii C++20'de,
en önemli araçlardan biri konseptler,
konseptlerin gelmesiyle,
olanak da çok arttı.
Ama konseptlere değinmesek de,
mesela tahmin edin,
şöyle yazarsak,
bu neyin karşılığı,
sanki,
karşılığında aşağıya yazalım,
template type name de,
auto,
funk,
bu sefer de
trf,
x'in karşılığı.
anlaşıldı,
değil mi?
Efendim,
burada,
auto ref,
x yazmak yerine,
auto ref ref koyarsak,
bu da trf,
ref,
yani,
geçen dersi öğrendiğimiz,
ama net işe yarayacağı,
konusunda,
henüz uzun uzun konuşmadığımız,
böyle parametreye ne deniyordu?
forwarding reference,
ya da universal reference,
yani,
böyle yazsak da,
forwarding reference,
forwarding reference aralığı,
herhangi bir şekilde,
bir fark yok.
Şimdi bu,
C++ 20'nin,
kullanılmasının,
yaygınlaşmasıyla birlikte,
özellikle fonksiyon şablonlarında,
bunun kullanılmasını,
efendim,
herhangi bir şekilde,
bir sakınca olmaması durumunda,
artık işlerin birinci tercihi,
yazma konusunda da,
pratik olduğu için,
bu sentaksi kullanmak.
Şimdi bunun dışında,
birkaç tane daha önemli not,
arkadaşlar,
bir sınıf,
jenerik olmasa da,
jenerik sözcüğünü,
ne anlamda kullandığımı,
biliyorsunuz,
yani bir sınıfın kendisi,
sınıf şablonu olmasa da,
sınıfın statik ya da,
non-statik veya fonksiyonları,
fonksiyon şablonu olabilir.
Bu da,
sık karşımıza çıkan bir durum.
Yani mesela bakınız,
class my class,
public,
şimdi eğer şöyle olsaydı,
bu,
non-statik member function,
ama bir template değil.
Mesela burada,
bu fonksiyonun,
parametresi,
inter'den olsun.
ama bir de şuna bakın,
template type name t,
arkadaşlar,
void foo,
t.
Şimdi sınıfın foo fonksiyonu,
bir fonksiyon şablonu.
Bu ne demek?
Örneğin,
my class sınıfı türünden,
bir nesnem olsaydı,
normal,
şimdiye kadar gösterdiğim,
free function olan,
fonksiyon şablonlarına göre,
bir farkı yok.
yine deduction yapılacak.
Örneğin,
m.foo,
45.
Bu durumda,
derleyici,
sınıfa,
int parametreli bir,
ne yazacak?
Arkadaşlar,
fonksiyon yazacak.
yani bu fonksiyon şablonunun,
int specialization'ı oluşturacak.
Ama ben,
örneğin,
m.foo,
int yerini,
buraya double argüman gönderseydim,
şimdi,
bir specialization daha oluşturulacaktı.
Bu sefer,
derleyicinin oluşturacağı,
specialization'da,
fonksiyonun parametresi,
double türünden olacaktı.
yani,
bir sınıfın,
üye fonksiyonu,
statik ya da,
non-statik üye fonksiyonu,
arkadaşlar,
ne olabilir?
Bir,
fonksiyon şablonu,
olabilir.
Hatta,
bu bir operatör fonksiyonu bile olabilir.
Mesela bakın,
operatör,
t.
Bu da belki,
özel durum olarak,
alınmalı.
t türüne,
dönüşüm yapan,
operatör,
t fonksiyonu.
int türüne,
dönüşüm için,
derleyici operatör,
int fonksiyonu yazacak,
double türüne dönüşüm için,
derleyici,
tabii,
bağlam gerektiğinde,
gerektirdiğinde,
operatör,
double fonksiyonu yazacak.
Evet,
hatta,
sınıfın,
örneğin,
konstruktörü,
yine,
bir sınıf şablonu,
bir fonksiyon şablonu olabilir.
Bunu da ileride,
konuşmamız gereken,
belki ileri düzeyde,
konulardan biri.
Ama şimdi,
önce,
temel konuları bir halledelim,
ileri konulara ayrıca bakmamız gerekiyor.
Peki,
şimdi,
kaldığımız yere artık geri dönebiliriz.
Arkadaşlar,
fonksiyon şablonlarında,
C++20 ile gelen özellikleri saymazsak,
fonksiyonun,
geri dönüş değeri,
türü için,
ya türü kendimiz belirliyoruz,
örneğin,
yani örneğin,
E,
U,
T.
Böyle bir fonksiyon şablonunda,
eğer T türü int ise,
bu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri türü int olacak.
T double ise,
bu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri türü,
double olacak.
ikinci olanak,
fonksiyonun,
buraya dikkat,
arkadaşlar,
geri dönüş değeri türünün,
trailing return type yapılması.
Şimdi,
uzun uzun trailing return type'dan bahsetmiştik,
biraz daha bahsetmek istiyorum.
Şimdi,
trailing return type,
aslında gerçekten,
çok da,
güzel,
işe yarayan bir mekanizma,
arkadaşlar.
Neden?
Hem,
jenerik olmayan kodda,
hem de jenerik kodda,
kullanılabiliyor.
Hem jenerik olmayan kodda,
hem de jenerik kodda kullanılabiliyor.
Jenerik olmayan kodda kullanılmasına fayda sağladığı senaryolardan bahsettim.
Aslında,
orada başka senaryolar da var.
Ama,
en tipi,
fonksiyonun örneğin,
geri dönüş değeri,
biraz daha karmaşık bir türse,
o zaman,
okun sağ tarafına yazmak,
onu,
daha kolay okunur,
yazılır hale getiriyor.
İşte,
mesela,
fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerinin,
function pointer olması,
ya da fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerinin,
bir array türüne,
pointer ya da,
referans olması.
Mesela,
bakın,
auto,
who,
arkadaşlar,
int,
izleyin
return are
derliyorum
bir hata yok
bakın burada çok net olarak
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri türünün
bu tür olduğu açık
ama şimdi
training return type
kullanmayın desem
bunu
yazmakta zorlanabilirsiniz
ya bir type def bildirimi yapacaksınız
arkadaşlar
yani türeş isim bildirimi yapacaksınız
ya da eğer
C'den gelen bilgileriniz
sağlamsa
doğrudan fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri türünün
bu olduğunu bir şekilde
gösterebilmeniz lazım
bilen var mı
mesela fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
şu referans
deklaratörü
şuradan paranteze aldık
dizinin elemanlarının
dizinin elemanlarının türünü koyduk
göşeri parantez
derliyorum
arkadaşlar böyle bir fonksiyonu muhtemelen hiç yazmadınız
yani en azından bu sentaksı kullanmadınız
ama C'de de
tabi C'de olsaydı bu
ne olacaktı
diziye pointer döndürecekti
C'de
diziye referans yok
ama az önce söylediğim gibi
böyle
karmaşık
algılanması zor
yazılarken
hata yapma riski de yüksek
onun yerine
auto return type'ı kullanıyoruz
auto
u
efendim
int
ampersan
eğer
diziye
pointer
döndürüyor olsaydı
buraya
yıldız koyacaktım
ama burası da
adres operatörü olacaktı
şimdi de
C'de olduğu gibi
fonksiyonu geri dönüş
diğeri
bir dizi türü ne
ne arkadaşlar
pointer
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
onun dışında
başka nasıl bir faydası
olabilir
yani
template kodun haricinde
birkaç örnek daha vereyim
bakın şimdi
güzel bir örnek daha
class
my class
and
class
nested
şimdi bu sınıfların
isimleri çok daha uzun
isimler de olabilirdi
değil mi
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri
nested
bu
parametreleri
vesaire yazmıyorum
şimdi ben bu fonksiyonu
yani sınıfın
dokuzuncu satırda
bildirilen
arkadaşlar
bu isimli fonksiyonu
eğer
namespace içinde
tanımını yapsaydım
şöyle yazmak zorundaydım
my class'ın
nested'i
türünden
geri dönüş
değeri olan
çünkü burası
class kokunun içinde
değil
dolayısıyla bu ismi
nitelemem gerekiyor
my class'ın
full fonksiyonu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
verleyelim
ama şimdi böyle yazmak yerine
bakın
bu tür durumlarda
artık
trailing return type'ı
yazdığımız yer
class kok içinde olduğu için
doğrudan
buraya
nitelemeden ismi
yazabiliyorum
böyle faydası
olmuyor
yani trailing return type
illa daha çok
jenerik kodda
kullanılıyor
ama illa jenerik kodda
olmak zorunda
değil
yani jenerik olmayan
kodda da
kullanılabilir
bunun dışında
yine böyle
trailing return type'ı
kullanmak isteyebileceğimiz
başka temalar da
olabilir
mesela bakın bu
çok güzel bir örnek
örnek benim değil
arkadaşlar
ama açıklama yapacağım size
biraz anlamanız
şey olabilir
zor olabilir
biraz
belki şu andaki
seviyemizin üstünde
şimdi
struct match
ben isimleri değiştirdim
diye bir tür var
yok bunu ben yazmışım
struct match
diye bir tür var
sınıf
burada
struct sadece
public yapmak için
yazım kolay da sağlasın
diye
bu sınıfın bir
veri elemanı
non-static
data member
şimdi bakınız
arkadaşlar
begin fonksiyonu
constueye fonksiyon
trailing return type
kullanmış
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri bu tür
değeri
aslında
becle type
operatörünü
hatırlayın
mvek
nesnesinin
begin fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
bu ifadenin
türü neyse
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü o
şimdi bir şeye
dikkatinizi çekmek
istiyorum
arkadaşlar
normalde
bu constueye fonksiyon
değil mi
fakat
constueye fonksiyonu
olmasına rağmen
burada
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri
türünü
decle type
ile belirtiyorum
fakat şimdi
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri
türünü
trailing return
type
yapmak yerine
aslında bir
sentaks hatası
da oluşturmayacak
şekilde
isme end
olan fonksiyona
bakın
sol tarafında
yani fonksiyonun
normal geri dönüş
değeri
türünün
yazıldığı
yere
yazdığımızı
düşünelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
nesne
bu
üye fonksiyon
constueye fonksiyon
olduğu için
buraya dikkat
burada
belki
hatırlayacaksınız
arkadaşlar
constueye fonksiyon
olduğu için
içinde sınıfın
veri elemanları
consta olarak kabul
ediliyor
dolayısıyla
buradaki
mwek'in
end fonksiyonunu
çağırdığım zaman
sentaks hatası
oluyor
olmasının
nedeni
arkadaşlar
burada
tür uyuşmazlığı
kompeynörlere
geldiğimizde
göreceğiz
yani öyle durumlar
var ki
training return
type'ı
kullanmakla
geri dönüş
değeri türünü
doğrudan
yazmak
arasında
sentaks açısından
farklılık
oluşuyor
ama
geçen derste
kaldığımız yere
gelelim
training return
type'ın
en çok
kullanıldığı
yer
jenerik
programlama
tarafı
dedi ki
öyle bir
fonksiyon
olsun ki
fonksiyonun
efendim
parametre
değişkeni var
fakat
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
parametre
değişkeniyle
oluşturulacak
bir
ifadenin
türü
yapılmak
isteniyor
bunun için
decal type'ı
kullanıyorum
arkadaşlar
örneğin
decal type
x'in
full fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
neyse
full fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
olsun
ama burada
x'in
skopi içinde
olmadığımdan
hata oluyor
buraya auto
yazıp
trailing return
type kullandığımda
arkadaşlar
artık
decal type
operatörünün
spesifarını
kullandığım
yer
doğrudan
neresi
skopi içinde
yani parametre
değişkeni olan
ismin
skopi içinde
böylece
sentaks hatası
olmuyor
böylece
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerin
türünün
jenerik olarak
belirlenmesinde
parametre değişkeni
ya da parametre
değişkenlerini
ne yapabiliyoruz
arkadaşlar
kullanabiliyoruz
bu arada bir yanlış
anlama olmasın
diye özellikle söyleyeyim
bunu yapmanın
yine bir yolu var
ama çok daha
verbi
henüz görmediğimiz
bazı araçları
kullanarak
buraya da aslında
ben
öyle bir ifade
yazabilirdim
bunun için
henüz görmediğimiz
decal var
arkadaşlar
jenerik fonksiyonunu
kullanıp
onunla birlikte
decal type'ı
kullanmam gerekiyor
ama
az önce gösterdiğim
gördüğünüz gibi
son derece
pratik
arkadaşlar
devam edin
şimdi
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerinin
trailing return type'ı
olması
sentaksına
epey bir
değindik
örnekler
verdik
ama bir de
c++ 14'le gelen
ne var
auto return type var
yani auto return type'la
trailing return type
birbiriyle bir kere
aynı şey
değil
kuralları da
farklı
sentaksı da
auto return type
trailing return type'ın
çoğu zaman
yerini
tutabilir
ama her zaman
değil
bu konuda özellikle
ben birkaç tane
çok da okunan
blog yazısında
bu hatanın
yapıldığını
gördüm
hep şöyle
demişler
auto return type
geldiğine göre
trailing return type'ın
hiçbir
hükmü kalmadı
gibi
bu kesinlikle
yanlış
şimdi
auto return type
nasıl
öyle ona bir bakalım
yani auto return type
nasıl bir sentaksa sahip
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
türünün
yerine
auto key
örgünü
yazıyorsunuz
bu
jenerik bir fonksiyon
olabilir
olmak zorunda
değil
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
buraya
auto'yu
yazdık
fonksiyonun
ismi
bu
örneğin
int
x
herhangi bir fonksiyon
için
bunu yazabilirsiniz
bu durumda
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
fonksiyonun
return ifadesinden
ortaya çıkacak
yani return ifadesinden
deduction yoluyla
anlaşılacak
mesela
şöyle yazsaydım
return
x
herhangi bir
anlam aramayın
verleyici
normal
şimdiye kadar
gördüğümüz
template argument
deduction'da
ya da
auto type
deduction'da
olan kurallarla
bir
deduction'ı
gerçekleştirecekti
ama bu sefer
bu tür
yani
dedius edilen
tür
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri türü
olacaktı
bu ifadenin
türü
int olduğu için
derleyici
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
değeri
türünü
int
yapacak
örneğin
return ifadesi
şöyle
olsaydı
bu ifadenin
türü
double olduğu için
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri türü
double olacaktı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
tekrar söylüyorum
bunun için
auto return type
kullanmak için
illa bir
jenerik kod
olması
gerekmiyor
hatta bildirimi
yapabiliyorsunuz
ama
sadece
bildirimi
yaparak
bu fonksiyonu
çağıramazsınız
çünkü
derleyicinin
bu durumda
çıkarım yapı
imkanı yok
yani
bildirimin
kendisinde
herhangi bir şekilde
bir sentaks
hatası yok
ama
mesela bu bildirime
dayanarak
bildirim burada
olsaydı
hanım burada
görünseydi
ve ben
diyelim ki
fonksiyon çağrısını
burada yapsaydım
derleyici bu durumu
sentaks hatası
olarak değerlendirecekti
çünkü bu noktada
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
diğerinin
türünü
çıkarım
yapma
imkanı
olmadığı için
anlaşıldı mı
eğer
birden fazla
return statement
varsa
o return statementlarda
geri dönüş
diğeri
türünün
aynı
olması gerekiyor
mesela şöyle bir kod
yazamazsınız
ip x
ondan
büyükse
return 1
as
return
3.4
bakın
yine
derleyici
iki tane
return statement
olduğu için
birinde
int
türünden
ifade
diğerinde
double türden
ifade
bu durumda
buraya baksa
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türünün
int olması
gerekiyor
diğer yere
baksa
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
double olması
gerekiyor
dolayısıyla
derleyici
durumu
sentaks hatası
olarak değerlendirecek
yani birden fazla
return statement
varsa
arkadaşlar
orada
hepsinde
tür
değer değil
tabi
return
ifadesinin
türü
aynı
olmak zorunda
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
illa
tek başına
auto
olmak zorunda
değil
mesela
sınır olabilir
mi
auto
ref
arkadaşlar
auto
ref
ya da
const
auto
ref
olabilir
ben örnekleri
hep
auto
keyword'ün
specifier'in
tek başına
yazılmasına
veriyorum
ama
ne olmak
zorunda
değil
auto
tek başına
bulunmak
zorunda
değil
evet
jenerik
kodla
bir şey
dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor
şimdi
auto
return type
ile
trailing
return type
aynı
değil
mesela
bakınız
şöyle
olsaydı
diyelim ki
bu fonksiyonun
referans
parametresi var
şimdi
return
x
auto
type
deduction'a
göre
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
int mi
int ref mi
int
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
int ref olması
için
burada referans
deklaratörü
olması lazım
şimdi bu fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değeri
int ref
dolayısıyla
çıkarımda da
bu fark
yaratıyor
yani şöyle bir şey
yapamazsınız
buraya auto
yazdım
arkadaşlar
buraya
fu yazdım
efendim ne bileyim
trf
x
şimdi siz
örneğin
şöyle bir ifade
yazarsanız
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
ne olma
ihtimali
kalmaz
arkadaşlar
referans
olma ihtimali
kalmaz
referans
her zaman
düşer
yani bu durumda
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
örneğin
t türü
int ise
int olacak
t türü
my class ise
my class
olacak
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
dolayısıyla
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
örneğin
trailing return
type yapılması
farklı bir şey
mesela şu örneği
veriyorum ben
örnek biraz zorlayabilir
şimdi iki tane
fonksiyonu
yazacağım
template
type name
t
bu fonksiyonun
ismi
print
a olsun
yani iki tane
birbirine benzer
konursam
print
1 olsun
efendim
post
t
ref
easy
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
pre
return
type
olsun
arkadaşlar
decal
type
to see out
oyu stream
dahil edelim
to see out
k
return
to see out
e
şimdi soru
bu ifadenin
decal type
herkes hatırlıyor
değil mi
decal type
tür çıkarımının nasıl
yapıldığını
herkes hatırlıyor
mu
sanırım
söyleyin bakalım
decal type'ın operanda
bir ifade olduğunda
tür çıkarımı
nasıl yapılıyordu
ifadenin value
kategorisine
bağlıydı
değil mi
üç tane ihtimal
var
ifadenin value
kategorisi
arkadaşlar
l value ise
geri dönüş
değeri
sol taraf
referans türü
ifadenin
value kategorisi
pr value ise
referans olmayan
tür
x value ise
r value
referans türü
bunu hatırlıyor musunuz
decal type'ı anlatırken
söylemiştim
tekrar edeyim mi
o konuyu
herkesin bir hatırlaması
gerekiyor
tamam
bir kez daha
buraya geri döneceğim
müsaadenizle
bir kez daha
orayı
anlatacağım
bakın şimdi
decal type
generic programlamanın
yıldızlarından biri
çok önemli
decal type'ı
specifier
type
deduction'da
kullanıyor
değil mi
şimdi decal type'ın
o dersi anlatmıştım
ama unutmuş
olabilirsiniz
hızlı bir şekilde
tekrar edeceğim
takıldığınız bir yere
olursa hemen sorun
decal type'la
herkesin
kafasını karıştıran
kısım neydi
iki tane
ayrı kural seti var
birincisi
decal type'ın
operandanın
bir
identifier olması
arkadaşlar
bu durumda
bu identifier
nasıl
deklare edilmişse
o türü elde ediyorsunuz
çok kısa bir
decal type
tekrar yapalım mı
mesela bakınız
int
x
eşittir
decal type
x
bu bir tür mü
kave
is it a type
yes
it is
which type is it
hangi tür
cevap
int
şimdi soru
bu
const olsaydı
burada const
falan düşecek miydi
Alihan
hayır
x nasıl
deklare edilmişse
o
yani şu anda
örneğin
şöyle bir değişken
tanımlasam
neden
sentaks hatası
çünkü decal type'ı elde ettiğim
tür
constant
must be
initialized
oysa initialized
etmedim
herkes hatırlıyor mu
evet
buna ne de dahil
arkadaşlar
nokta operatörüyle
ok operatörüyle
oluşturulan
isimler de dahil
yani
örneğin
truck
net
double
x
ve ben şimdi
net türünden
my net
decal type
in
nokta
x
bu tür hangi tür
bu isim nasıl
deklare edilmişse
o tür
yani şu anda
double türü
bravo
burada
referans
deklare türü
olsaydı
bu tür
şimdi
arkadaşlar
tabi
bu durumda
efendim
sentaks
diye
default
constructor
deleted
olacaktı
ama onu
o problemi
çözersem
buradan yine
referans
süreli
ediliyor
değil mi
ona da bir örnek
vereyim
isterseniz
yasağa
bakınız
class
my class
her aynı
bir sınıf
my class
me
ref ref
re
arkadaşlar
eşit bir
stud
move
me
bekl type
re
hangi tür
buradan elde edilen
türü hangi tür
cevap
bravo
my class
ref ref
örneğin burada
const
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
burası önemli
değil
bu durumda
re ne olacak
ne
const
düşecek
ne
referanslık
düşecek
bu durumda
re
arkadaşlar
re diyorum
deklare elde edilen
tür
const
my class
ref
türü
şimdi
demin size
söylediğim
ikinci
kural seti
ben
böyle anlatıyorum
birinci kural seti
bir yana identifier söz konusu
ikinci kural seti
bekl type'ın operandı
herhangi bir expression
int x eşittir
arkadaşlar
x artı 3
operand bir identifier mı
kave
deniz
ayağın
hayır
o zaman ikinci kural seti
uygulanacak
ikinci kural setini
buraya tekrar yazıyorum
neye bakılıyor
value kategoriye
value kategori derken
primary value kategori
3 tane value kategori var
neydi bunlar
l value
söyleyin
pr value
bravo
ve
x value
ifadenin
value kategori
l value ise
elde edilen tür
sol taraf referansı türü
ifade
pr value ise
referansı olmayan tür
x value ise
star taraf referansı türü
şimdi söyleyin
bu ifade
bu ifadenin
value kategorisi ne
tabi
pr value
o zaman bu tür ne
p yani
int
ifadenin türü int olduğuna göre
anlaşıldı mı
ama bakın şimdi
int yıldız ptr
eşittir adres x
decotype
yıldız ptr
identifier mi expression mı
cevap verin
cevap
expression
dolayısıyla value
kategoriye bakıyoruz
rastl
value kategori
l value
o zaman
bu
hangi tür
cevap
int
int değil
demin yazdım ya
l value ise
sol taraf
referansı türü
elde edilir
mesela
böyle bir
değişken
tanımlasam
kave
neden sentaks
atası
çünkü
l value
reference
must be
initialized
bravo
anlaşıldı değil mi
bir örnek daha verelim
arkadaşlar
mesela
iseyin
olacak iş değil ama
int
ref
bu
bu ifadenin value
kategorisini
geri dönüş
değeri
r value
referans
türü olan
bir fonksiyona
yapılan
çağrı
ifadesi
value
kategori
olarak
hatırlıyor musunuz
x value
bravo
çağrı
o zaman
decal type
o hangi
tür
cevap
int
ref
mesela
bakınız
x
eşittir
neden
sentaks
hatası
değil
çünkü
r value
referansa
ile
değer verdim
ama
bakın
int
eval
decal type
bu
x
eşittir
eval
şimdi
sentaks
hatası
çünkü
buradan
el
aşağıya
yorum satırı
ile yazayım
buradan
elde edilen tür
int
ref
dolayısıyla
sizin x'iniz
int
ref
l value
ile
ilk değer
veremezsiniz
decal type
ilişkin kuralları
herkes hatırladı mı
özellikle
önümüzdeki derslerde
çok daha önemli
olacak
evet
süpersiniz
arkadaşlar
tamam
şimdi
son kez daha
söyleyelim
eğer
decal type
operandı
identifier
ise
o identifier
ne şekilde
hangi türden
deklar edilmişse
o tür
pical type
operandı
alent
file
değil
expression
ise
işte
o expression
value
kategorisi
l value
ise
t ref
diğer value
ise
t
x value
ise
t ref
ref
anlaşıldı mı
evet
yalnız
bu mülakatlarda
falan da
nedense
sormayı
çok sevdikleri
şöyle bir
soru var
dikkatli izleyin
şimdi
int
x eşittir
decal type
x yazmakla
parantez içinde
x yazmak
birbirinden
farklı anlamda
bakın
konuyu en güzel gösteren
örnek olduğu için
hep mülakatlarda
c plus plus mülakatlarında
zorlamak için
böyle bir soru soruyorlar
ya da bu bir şekilde
sorunun içinde
geçiyor
bilmeniz gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
bu tür hangi tür
burada
operand
alent
file olduğu için
birinci
bural seti
kullanılacak
dolayısıyla
buradan elde
edilen tür
doğrudan
declaration type
in
fakat
burada ismi
bir parantez
içine aldığım zaman
artık isim kuralı değil
expression kuralı
geçerli olduğu için
bravaka ve
bu durumda
bu ifadenin
value kategorisi
l value olduğu için
int ref elde edecek
bakın isterseniz arkadaşlar
dekotype x
y
sentax hatası
ama
dekotype
arkadaşlar
x
z
bir sentax hatası
değil
çünkü buradan
referans türü
elde edildi
şimdi
bu açıklamalardan
sonra
trailing return type
ile auto return type'ın
her zaman aynı anlama
gelmeyeceğini
göstermek için
bir örnek yazıyordum
bakın şimdi
burada
trailing return type
auto
ne diyelim
kri
bir
fonksiyonun parametresi
conste
ref olsun
trailing return type
dekotype
tam burada parantezi
açmıştık
hatırlıyor musunuz
to see out
bu arada
dekotype konusunu
anlatırken bahsetmiştim
ama unutmuş olabilirsiniz
diye tekrar söyleyeyim
dekotype'ın
operanda olan ifade
unevaluated context
yani onun için
işlem kodu üretilmiyor
dolayısıyla
tanımsız
davranış da olabilir
tanımsız davranış
oluşturan bir ifade
olduğunda
tanımsız davranış olmayacak
onu unevaluated context
konusunda
anlatmıştım
yani örneğin
onu da bir aradan
çıkartalım
sık sık geri dönüyorum
kusura bakmayın
ama önemli
mesela bakın
int
yıldız p
p null pointer
decotype
yıldız p
arkadaşlar
tamam
elde edilen tür
int ref
ama
tanımsız davranış var mı
null pointer'ı
dereferans ettiğim için
hayır
çünkü burası
unabulated context
ya da başka bir örnek
int a
decal type
a
r
eşittir
x
int x
eşittir
arkadaşlar
artı artı
r
x
6 oldu mu
olmadı mı
x
6 oldu mu
olmadı mı
cevap oldu
neden oldu
güzel bir soru bakın
çünkü
bu
ifade
l value expression
olduğu için
elde edilen tür
int ref
dolayısıyla
burada referans
dektatörü
olmasa da
bu aslında
arkadaşlar
bir
nedir
sol taraf
referansı
dolayısıyla
r x'e
referans olduğu için
r'yi arttırdığında
x arttırmış oldum
anlaşıldı
anlaşıldı mı
evet burada yine
dikkatimizi çekmesi gereken
bir başka nokta
dizinin boyutu
10 olmasına rağmen
dizinin
20 indisi
elemanına
erişme ifadesi
herhangi bir
şekilde bir
undefined
behavior
oluşturmuyor
çünkü
unavoidated
context
x
const
trf
x
biraz
size zorlayacak
bir soru olacak
ama
olsun
return
stu
c
x
bu fonksiyonun
pri 1 fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü ne
o stream cevabı
yanlış
o stream ref
bravo
cengizhan
oğuzhan
aya
bravo
neden o stream ref
çünkü
burada çağrılan
fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
e
geri dönüş
değeri
mesela bu fonksiyonu
şöyle çağırırsam
pri 1
burada çağrılan
fonksiyon
yani bu ifadenin
türü
x'in türü
int olduğunda
o stream ref
geri dönüş
değeri
o stream
referans
yani sol taraf
referansı
dolayısıyla
bizim fonksiyonumuzun
geri dönüş
değeri de
sol taraf
referansı
anlaşıldı mı
burayı anladınız mı
mesela
bakınız
soru
pri 1
burada bir
sentaks hatası
var mı
cevap
sentaks hatası
yok
çünkü fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
arkadaşlar
l value
referansı
o stream
ama şimdi
bakın
fonksiyon
şöyle
olsaydı
burada da
artık
auto type
deduction
olacaktı
şunu da
düzeltelim
auto type
deduction
olacaktı
arkadaşlar
evet
auto type
deduction
olduğu için
auto type
deduction
da
burada
referans
deklaratörü
olmadan
bu ifade
arkadaşlar
burada
çağrılan
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
sol taraf
referansı
olsa da
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
referans
türü
değil
değil mi
şimdi
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
o stream
türü
demin
sormuştum
o stream
dedi ya
bazı arkadaşlarım
şimdi bu
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
o stream
çünkü
auto
aradaki farkı
anladınız mı
arkadaşlar
aradaki farkı
anladınız mı
evet
peki
şimdi
dolayısıyla
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
o stream
olduğu için
olsam
o konuyu
henüz
anlatmadım
yani
bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
auto
ref ref olması
çok önemli
ama
henüz
anlatmadım
o konuyu
yani
orada
şimdi
bir cümleyle
anlatabileceğim
bir konu
değil
o yüzden
biraz bana
müsaade
etmelisiniz
ama
bakın
şimdi
buraya
arkadaşlar
izleyin
şimdi
syntax
hatası
oldu
neden
syntax
hatası
oldu
çünkü
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
o stream
olduğu için
kopyalama
semantiği
devreye
girdi
ve
kopyalama
semantiği
devreye
girince
copy
constructor
delete
edildi
için
syntax
hatası
oldu
yani
buradan
şu sonucu
çıkartıyoruz
grailing
return
type
arkadaşlar
auto
return
type
her zaman
ne
değil
aynı
şey
değil
anlaşıldı
mı
evet
c++
20'ye
geldiğimiz
zaman
bakın
olay
o zaman
daha da
eğlenceli
hale
geliyor
demiştik
ya
şöyle
fonksiyon
yazabiliyorsunuz
auto
mesela
bakın
auto
sum
x
auto
y
parametreyi
konser
referans
yapsam
daha iyi olur
ama
sadece size
göstermek
için
return
x
artı
y
izleyin
auto
val
eşittir
sum
2,4.5
söyleyin bakalım
val'in türü ne
cevap
double
ama neden
double oldu
birinci
template
parametresi
için
çıkarım
int
olarak
yapıldı
yani
fonksiyonun
derleyicim yazdığı
specialization'da
bu int
bu double
dolayısıyla
bu ifadenin
türü
toplama operatörün
operanda
biri int
biri double
olduğunda
tabi c'den
bildiğimiz
kurallarla
bu ifadenin
türü
arkadaşlar bu durumda
double oldu
dolayısıyla
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
double olduğu için
bu seferde
val için
auto type
deduction
yapıldı
val için
auto type
deduction
yapıldığında
val'in türü de
gördüğünüz gibi
double oldu
soru
val'in türü ne
bravo
alian
bitti arkadaşlar
her ne kadar fonksiyona
çar göndersem de
evet fonksiyonun
parametre değişkenleri
çar
ama çar
artı çar
integral
promotion'da
bu ifadenin türü
ne oldu
int oldu
dolayısıyla
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
türü
int oldu
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
bu abreviyeti template
sentax
gerçekten
iş çok
kolaylaştırdı
inşallah
vaktimiz yetersin
pek
gelecek gibi
görünmüyor
c++
giderek
büyüyor
konseptleri de
bu kursa
dahil etseydik
orada
bu
abreviyeti template
sentax
konseptler ve
bunların
birlikte
kullanılması
çok daha
hoşunuza gidecek
eğlenceli
generic programlama
araçları haline geliyor
peki o zaman
o da return
spam ve range
görecek miyiz
emran çeyneğin
sorusu
arkadaşlar
şimdi
gönül isterken
şeyi gösterelim
bu yüzden
şu ikisi arasında
bir seçim yapmamız
gerekiyor
biraz kursla ilgili
konuşalım
ciddi konuşalım
birincisi
arkadaşlar
konuları
yüzeysel olarak
anladık
geçmek
kiminim hiç
sevmediğim bir şey
bireysel olarak
bazen kurumlara
verilen eğitimlerde
mecbur
böyle yapmak
zorunda kalıyorum
ve o eğitim
çekilmez hale geliyor
arkadaşlar
yani
böyle sanki
Udemy eğitimleri
gibi
o beni de
tatmin etmez
siz de tatmin etmez
ya da
konuları
iyi öğrenip
ayrıntılarıyla
kritik yerleriyle
üretimde
ya da
mülakatlarda
böyle her şeye
hazırlıklı olacak
şekilde
konuyu iyi
öğrenmek ama
bazı konuları
kurs dışında
bırakmak
normalde
ben
hem
studspen'i
hem de
stud range'si
yani genel olarak
range's kütüphanesini
ileri C++
kursunda anlatıyorum
yani bazı konuları
burada maalesef
feda etmemiz gerekiyor
çünkü 200 saat
şimdi bakalım
zaten neredeyse
kursun
yarısına
yaklaşmış durumdayız
67 tersi
yakın bir yerdeyiz
evet
o zaman şöyle diyelim
Emirhan
vaktimiz yeterse
burada
yetmezse
inşallah
gelirseniz
ileri C++
kursunda
göreceğiz
şimdi fonksiyon
şablonlarına
belirli bir süre
ara vereceğim
arkadaşlar
ve
sınıf şablonlarına
bir giriş yapacağım
ama
bir iki hatırlatma
yine çok sık
tekrar edeyim ki
iyice otursun
arkadaşlar
template isterken
artık modern
C++'da
bizim template'lerimiz
şunlardı değil mi
function template
bahsettik
evet
tabii ki
henüz bahsetmediğiniz
sonlar da var ama
class template
şimdi görmeye
başlayacağız
sevgili arkadaşlar
onun dışında
variable template
alias template
ve
concept'ler
şimdi
function template
ve class template
modern C++
öncesinde vardı
variable template
ve alias template
bunlar
modern C++'a geldi
hatta
variable template
C++
14 standardıyla
geldi
konsept
konseptin
kendisi de bir template
bazı farklılıklar
olsa da
hem
syntax açısından
hem de
kullanılma amacı
bakımında
ama
sonuçta
konseptlerde
template'in bir kategorisi
olarak
görülmeli
arkadaşlar
modern C++'a gelen
önemli bir özellikti
template
parametrelerine ilişkin
şimdi
template parametreleri
ne olabiliyordu
onu da bir hatırlatalım
type
parametre
non-type
pamplet
parametre
bu
modern C++
önce de
zaten böyleydi
yani
bunlar modern C++'a
eklenen araçlar
değil
bazı yenilikler
eklemeler
getirir seti
üç kategoride
vardı
ama
modern C++'ın
getirdiği
en önemli
yeniliklerden biri
yine
devrimsel nitelikte
template parametrelerinin
İngilizcesiyle
parametre paketi
olabilmesi
İngilizcede
kullanılan terim
parameter pack
ben Türkçe
doğrudan çeviriyorum
parametre paketi
diyorum
ve işte bu
parametre paketi
kavramıyla
oluşturulan
template'leri
popüler olarak
variadic
template deniyor
yani
variadic
template
template'lerin
parametre paketine
sahip olma özelliği
modern C++'dan
önce yoktu
ve
böyle hani
kafife alınacak
bir sentaks değil
birçok şeyin
günümüzde rahatlıkla
yapılabiliyor olması
modern C++'da
jenerik programlama
tarafına eklenen
bu
ister
variadic template
değil
isterseniz de
o terimi
kullanmadan
parametre paketi
terimini
kullanın
her ikisinde de
kastetilen şey
aslında
aynı
yani
variadic template
ayrı bir template
kategorisi
değil
ama
modern C++'da
template'lere
yönelik
eklenen
çok önemli
bir araç
yani ne
olduğu ile ilgili
çok kısa
bahsedeyim
çünkü
ayrı bir alt başlık
olarak çok detaylı
incelememiz gerekiyor
tarfa alınacak
bir konu değil
arkadaşlar
ben şöyle bir
kod yazsaydım
bu template'in
kaç tane
parametresi var
template parametresi var
iki tane
type parametresi var
şimdi
bu
sınıf şablonu
olabilir
fonksiyon şablonu
orası önemli değil
ama
şöyle yazsaydım
bu template'in
bir tane
template parametresi
olacaktı
şöyle yazsaydım
bu template'in
üç tane
template
tür parametresi
olacaktı
ama bakın
modern C++'a gelen
en önemli
yenilik
arkadaşlar
şöyle yazarsam
type neyim
efendim
types
kullanılan
kullanılan isminin
ne olduğuna
bakmayın
ya da sınıf şablonu
ya da fonksiyon şablonu
olduğuna da
bakmayın
ileride göreceğiz
işte
burada
bu token'a ne deniyordu
C'den biliyoruz
elipsiz
token'ı deniyordu
değil mi
üç nokta token'ı
bu şekilde
oluşturulan
template parametresi
ya da parametrelerine
template parametre
paketi deniyor
bu şu demek
şimdi
sizin bu template'i
kullanma biçiminize
bağlı olarak
parametre paketinde
buna parametre paket
diyoruz
bir tane
iki tane
üç tane
en tane
tür parametresi
olabilir
yani örneğin
şöyle yazdığımızda
arkadaşlar
template parametre
paketinde
bir tane parametre
tür parametresi
var
ama şöyle yazdığımda
bu seferde
iki tane
tür parametresi
var
böyle yazdığımda
üç tane
tür parametresi
var
ona
template parametre
paketi
deniyor
özellikle
fonksiyon şablonlarında
çok sık
kullanılıyor
ama dediğim gibi
bu böyle
beş dakikada
anlatacak bir konu
değil
önde bazı
başka konuları
göreceğiz ki
ondan sonra
bu konuyu
iyi anlayabilelim
mesela
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
fonksiyon
şablonunun
variadik bir
fonksiyon şablonu
olduğunu söyleyebiliriz
burada
template
tür
parametre paketi
var
type parametre paketi
bu da
fonksiyonun
parametre paketi
yine bu
parametre paket
tür parametreler
içinde
non type
parametreler
içinde
template
parametreleri
içinde
geçerli
mesela şöyle
yazabilir miyim
int
arkadaşlar
x
bu da
non type
parametre
yani örneğin
şöyle yazdığımda
non type
parametre paketinde
sadece
on değeri var
şöyle yazdığımda
hem
on hem
yirmi
değeri var
yine
benzer
mantık
ama bunları
ileride
göreceğiz
sadece makro düzeyde
neler var
neler yok
arada ona
değiniyorum
efendim şimdi
sınıf şablonlarına
geçelim
fonksiyon şablonu
derleyiciye
bir fonksiyon
kodu
yazdırmanın
aracı
yani
function
template'i
instan
şey ettiğinde
derleyici
bir
function
kodu
oluşuyor
bir function
ona da işte
o fonksiyon
şablonun
o function
template'in
bir specialization'ı
diyoruz
class template'in
ise amacı
bir class
kodu oluşturmasını
sağlamak
derleyicinin
yani
class template'in
specialization'ı
bir sınıfın
kodu
arkadaşlar
özellikle
veri yapılarını
temsil eden
sınıflarda
ama sadece
onunla
sınırlı değil
genel olarak
veri yapısı
ya da sınıfın
genel yapısı
türden
bağımsız olmasına
rağmen
sınıfın
kodu
türe bağlı
mesela bakın
en basit örnek
olabilecek
en basit örneklerden
biri
şimdi
bizim bir
gerçi
standart
kütüphanemizde
zaten var ama
sanki
standart
kütüphaneden
bahsetmiyormuşum
gibi düşünün
kompleks
sınıfı
yani kompleks
sayıları
temsil eden
e şimdi
gelin ki
biz kompleks
sayıyı
oluştururken
gerçek kısmı
ve imajiner
kısmını
tutmak
istiyoruz
e şimdi
bunlar
double
olabilir
arkadaşlar
e bunlar
float
yapılmak
istenebilir
bunlar
long
double
yapılmak
istenebilir
hatta
belki de
arkadaşlar
bunlar
double gibi
kullanılabilen
fakat bir
custom type
olabilir
fakat
sınıfın
genel yapısı
bu
sanal kısmı
ve gerçek kısmı
hangi türlü
temsil edileceği
ile doğrudan
ilgili değil ki
öyle değil mi
mesela
sınıfın
public
interfejsinde
arkadaşlar
buradaki
fonksiyonlar
örneğin
real kısmını
get eden bir fonksiyon
olsa
e double
ise double
döndürecek
long
double
ise long
döndürecek
full
ise
float
döndürecek
şimdi işte
böylesi durumlarda
eğer sınıf
şablonu
genel
ben sınıf
şablonu
demek yerine
böyle sınıflara
generic
class da
diyorum
yani
standardını doğrudan
kullanılabilirim
değil
jenerik sınıflar
olmasaydı
biz
her farklı
eleman
türüne
sahip
sınıf için
ayrı bir kod
yazmamız
gerekecekti
o tekrar etmiş
olacaktık
ve bazı
başka
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
ele alacağımız
sakıncaları
olacaktı
ama şimdi
bunu bir
sınıf şablonu
olarak
oluşturduğumuzda
mesela
template
pipe
mp
class
complex
sınıfın
veri elemanları
t türünden
re
i
gerçek kodu
yazmıyorum
o yüzden
küçük küçük
detaylara
bakmayın
efendim
belki
sınıfın
get
real
isimli bir
fonksiyonu
olacak
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
t türü
olacak
örneğin
dolayısıyla
ben şimdi
derleyiciye
bu sınıf
şablonundan
bir sınıf
kodu
yazdırdığımda
complex
de
template
argümanı
olarak
double
kullanıldığında
derleyicinin
yazdığı sınıfta
veri elemanları
double olacak
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri türü
double olacak
olabilecek
en basit
örneklerden
biri
ama
işte
STL'deki
konteynerları
düşündüğün örneğin
dinamik dizi
bağlı liste
efendim
ikili arama
ağacı
bunlar genelde
türden bağımsız
ama
konteynerda
tutulacak
üyenin
türüne göre
implementasyonda
bazı türler
ve
interfeste
ve implementasyonda
farklı olacak
işte
bu sınıfların
kodunu
ayrı ayrı
yazmak yerine
o kodu
yazdıracak
adeta
meta kodu
oluşturuyoruz
bederleyici
bizim oluşturduğumuz
sınıf kodundan
arkadaşlar
onlarca
yüzlerce
binlerce
farklı
sınıf kodu
oluşturabilir
işte konumuz
bununla ilgili
mesela
aslında ben
bu fikirle
sizi ilk tanıştırmaya
çalıştığım
konu
bu
taşıma
sematiğinde
yavaş yavaş
smart pointer
nedir
ondan bahsetmiştik
arkadaşlar
düşün işte
smart pointer
sınıfları
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerin
hayatını
kontrol edecek
pointer like
sınıflar
yani kendisi
pointer
değil ama
pointer gibi
kullanılabilecek
sınıflar
dolayısıyla
böyle sınıflar
söz konusu
olduğunda
normalde
sınıfın
pointer'ı
sarmalaması
gerekiyor
ama
dinamik ömürlü
int türden
bir nesnenin
hayatını
kontrol edecekse
sarmaladığı
pointer
int yıldızı
olacak
string sınıfı
türünden
bir
efendim
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
kontrol edecekse
sarmaladığı
pointer
string yıldızı
olacak
dolayısıyla
onlarca
yüzlerce
binlerce
custom type
olduğuna göre
her birine
ilişkin
ayrı bir
akıllı
pointer sınıfı
oluşturmamız gerekiyor
işte bunları ayrı ayrı
yazmak yerine
derleyici
bunların
kodunu
yazacak bir
mekanizma
oluşturuyoruz
arkadaşlar
kodumuz
bunla ilgili
o zaman
şöyle başlayalım
bir sınıf
şablonunda
yine
template
anahtar
sözcüğü
yine
açısal
parantez
parantezin
içinde
yine
template
parametreleri
burada bir
fark yok
tür
parametresi
type parameter
non-type parameter
template parameter
olabilir
arkadaşlar
parametre paketi
olabilir
bunların ikisi
bir arada bulunabilir
ve ondan sonrası
normal
class
struct
union
anahtar
sözcükleriyle
gene
class'ımızı
oluşturuyoruz
mesela
diyelim ki
sınıfın
private bölümünde
burada
t türünden
bir
veri elemanı
burada
e türünden
bir
on eleman
dizi
burada
geri dönüş
değeri
t olan
efendim
ismi
get olan
bir fonksiyon
burada
geri dönüş
değeri
olmayan
ismi
set olan
bir fonksiyon
olsun
sadece böyle
temsili
gösteriyorum
şimdi
siz
bu sınıf
şablonundan
oluşturulacak
bir
specialization'ı
kullanmak istediğinizde
arkadaşlar
C++
17 ile
dile eklenen
bu sit adı
şimdilik
göz önünde
almazsak
template argümanı
ya da argümanların
ne olduğunu
kendiniz
belirtiyorsunuz
mesela
my class'ın
int
specialization'ı
böylece
aslında
yukarıdaki
sınıf
şablonundan
template
parametresi
karşılığı
template argümanının
int olarak
seçilmesiyle
oluşturulacak
bir
sınıf kodu
söz konusu
olacak
burada
bir takım
avantajları
olduğundan
bahsetmiştim
template'lerin
genel olarak
avantajları da var
dezavantajları da var
şimdi dezavantajlar
konusunu ayrıca
anlatacağım
örneğin
başlık dosyalarında
ne olacak
ne olmayacak
burada kullanılan
teknikler neler
bunlar hepsi
uzun uzun
ayrı alt başlıklarımız
fakat şimdi
bu bir sınıf türü
arkadaşlar
nasıl
class
neç
bir sınıfsa
my class'ın
int
specialization'ı
bir sınıf
my class'ın
kendisi
bir sınıf
mı
cevap
hayır
bu sınıf
şablonundan
instantiate
bu sınıf
şablonunun
instantiate
edilmesiyle
oluşturulacak
sınıflar
sınıfı
yani örneğin
my class'ın
int specialization
efendim
double specialization
derleyici
gerekli olan
noktalarda
bu sınıfı
bu sınıf
şablonundan
specialization'ı
instantiate edecek
örneğin siz
böyle bir sınıf
oluşturmak
istediğinizde
derleyicinin
oluşturacağı
class definition'da
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri int
olacak
efendim
sınıfın
veri elemanı
int türden
olacak
sınıfın
bu veri elemanı
int türden
bir dizi
olacak
eğer şöyle
olsaydı
bir
int pointer
dizisi
olacaktı
set fonksiyonunun
parametresi
constant
ref olacak
takip edebiliyor
muyuz?
işte
şimdiye kadar
gördüğümüz
bazı örneklerde
aslında biz
hep sınıf
şablonlarını
kullandık
mesela
string sınıfının
kendisi de
bir sınıf
şablonu
yani biz
şimdiye kadar
şöyle yazdık
ki o derste
ilk olarak
söylemiştim
sanki
stut
string
doğrudan
bir sınıfmış
gibi biz
bu sınıfı
kullandık
aslında stut
string
bir
türeş
ismi
eğer biz
o türeş
ismini
kullanmasaydık
stut
basic
string'in
char virgül
arkadaşlar
stut
chart
rates'in
böyle
uzun
bir
tür bilgisi
yazmak
zorunda
kalacaktık
stut
allocator
allocator'ın
char
açılımı
fakat bu türe
string
eş
ismi
verildiği
için
biz doğrudan
neyi
kullanıyoruz
string
ismini
kullanıyoruz
vektör
bir sınıf
şablonu
string
bir sınıf
şablonu
bazı örneklerde
kullandığımız
unique
ptr
bir sınıf
şablonu
nereye
baksak
STL'de
hemen her yerde
karşımıza
sınıf
şablonları
çıkacak
üçüncü
parti
kütüphanelerde
de
özellikle
bu
kütüphanesinde
de
öyle
önce sınıf
şablonunun
ne olduğunu
bir
anlamanızı
istiyorum
arkadaşlar
mesela
STL'in
en çok
kullanılan
sınıflarından
biri olan
stut
array'i düşündüm
array
ink dizilerini
sarmalayan
rap eden
aslında bir
rapper class
bir light rapper
e şimdi
ben
10 elemanlı
ink bir diziyi
sarmalamak
isteseydim
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
sınıf
oluşturacaktım
sınıfı
veri elemanı
olarak
10 elemanlı
bir dizi
koyacaktım
burada da
public
interfejsi
client'ların
işlerini
rahatlıkla
görmesi için
gerekli
fonksiyonları
üye fonksiyonları
belki
türleri
vesaireleri
koyacaktım
ama ben
10 elemanlı
bir
ink diziyi
sarmalayan
bir sınıf
yerine
örneğin
double
türden
20 elemanlı
bir diziyi
sarmalayan
bir sınıf
isteseydim
bu sefer de
sınıfın
veri elemanı
böyle olacaktı
arkadaşlar
ama şimdi
düşünün
STL'deki
array sınıfını
template
pipelame
t
sarmalanacak
c dizisinin
türü
stud size
t
kullanan
pipe parametre
size
bu da
sarmalanacak
dizinin
boyutu
olan
değer
efendim
class
diye
şöyle
struct
array
şöyle olduğunu
düşünün
arkadaşlar
temsili olarak
gösteriyorum
burada
elemanları
t türünden
olan
bir tane
dizi var
dizinin
boyutu da
size
kurdu
ona yönelik
bir
interfej var
vakit
geçtikçe
sınıf
şablonlarına
duyulan
ihtiyacın
ne kadar
önemli
olduğunu
yavaş
göreceksiniz
önce sınıf
şablonunun
ne olduğunu
anlatmaya
çalışıyorum
arkadaşlar
template parametresi
yine
küre ilişkini
olabilir
işte burada
az önceki
array örneğinde
non-type
parametre de
gerekiyor
değil mi
ya da
çok güzel
başka bir
örnek
arkadaşlar
bit set
sınıfı
sınıfı da
ESL'in
önemli
sınıflarından
biri
mesela
ben
32 tane
bit
seviyesinde
tutulacak
boolean
değişikini
bir bit
vektörü
olarak
kullanmak
için
bit
set
sınıf
şablonunun
bakın
bir tane
non-type
parametresi
var
örneğin
açılımı
olan
sınıfı
kullandığımda
arkadaşlar
terleyici
ayrı
bir sınıf
kodu
yazacak
örneğin
açılımını
kullandığımda
ayrı
bir sınıf
kodu
yazacak
20 açılımını
kullandığımda
ayrı bir
sınıf
kodu
yazacak
işte
STL
zaten
nereden
geliyor
bu konu
bittikten sonra
uzunluğunda
STL'e
başlayacağız
standart
pamphlet
library
bu kütüphanenin
yani
STL
dediğimiz
kütüphanenin
öğeleri
sınıf
şablonları
fonksiyon
değişken
şablonları
türeş
isim
şablonları
C++
20 ile
konseptler
hepsi bir
araya
gelerek
STL
dediğimiz
büyük
evasa
kütüphaneyi
oluşturuyorlar
şimdi
sınıf
şablonlarına
yönelik
genel
semtaksi
görmekle
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
normal sınıflarda
olduğu gibi
bir sınıf
şablonu
içinde
sadece
forward declaration
yapılabilir
ve
class
definition
da yapılabilir
örneğin
şöyle
deseydim
template
type
name
t
class
my
bir sınıf
şablonunun
sadece
bildirimi
bildirimlerde
template
parametresi
kullanılmayacağı
için
template
parametresine
isim
vermemek
daha iyi
olabilir
ama isim
de verebilirsiniz
duruma göre
mesela
şöyle bir
bildirimde
iki tane
template
parametresi
var
ikisi de
type
parametre
şöyle
olsaydı
bir tane
template
type
parametre
ama ikinci
template
parametresi
non-type
parametre
olacaktı
bu
sadece
declaration
değil mi
ama tabi
sınıfın
tanımını da
yapabiliriz
normal
sınıf tanımı
nasıl yapılıyorsa
ona çok
benziyor
mesela
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
type name
çok basit bir
sınıf şablonu
üretimde
oradan kullanılmaya
aday değil
ama
birlikte
çok basit bir
sınıf şablonun
üstünde
yavaş yavaş
syntax kurallarını
göstermeye
başlayalım
örneğin
instance'ları
counter olarak
kullanılacak
bir
sınıf
oluşturmak
istiyorum ki
daha önce benzer
böyle bir sınıf
yazmıştık
çok basit
toy example
olarak
close counter
ama
şöyle bir problem
var
daha doğrusu
şöyle bir problem
olduğunu düşünelim
counter'ımız
intürden de
olabilsin
efendim
long
türden de
olabilsin
long
long türünden
de olabilsin
o türün
seçimini
client kodu
yazan
programcıya
bırakmak
istiyorum
o yüzden
counter
sınıfını
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
bir sınıf
şablonu
olarak
oluşturmak
istiyorum
bu arada
şablonlar
template
kodlar
çok çok
büyük
çoğunlukla
hep
header
file'larda
olacak
onu
ayrı bir
alt başlık
altında
ele alacağız
şimdilik onu
düşünmeyin
nereye koyacağız
nasıl
organize edeceğiz
template
type name
t
ya da
yine
class
anahtar
sözcüğü
class t
class
counter
önemli olan
syntaxı
görmeniz
için
arkadaşlar
t ya da
t'ye bağlı
herhangi bir
türü
bu
class
definition
içinde
kullanabilirim
ama
sadece
t'ye bağlı
tür olmak
zorunda
değil
mesela
şöyle bir
class
my class
tekrar
counter'a
geri döneceğim
mesela şöyle bir
fonksiyon olabilir mi
int
bu
belki olabilir
bu fonksiyonun
ne parametreleri
ne geri dönüş
değeri türü
template
parametresine
bağlı
değil
yani örneğin
my class'ın
int açılımı
olsa da
my class'ın
double açılımı
da olsa
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
int
geri dönüş
değeri türü
int
ama örneğin
fonksiyon
şöyle bildirilmiş
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
my class'ın
int
specialization'ı
için
onun
foo
isimli
üye fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
int
parametresi
olacaktı
my class'ın
efendim
diyelim ki
stut
string
açılımı
için
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
string
parametresi
stut
string
olacaktı
yani
template parametresine
bağlı olabilir
ya da
olmayabilir
ikisi birden de
olabilir
mesela şöyle bir
fonksiyon olduğunu
düşünelim
efendim
my class'ın
int açılımının
açılım terimini
ne anlamda
kullandığımı
söylemiştim
my class'ın
int açılımının
geri dönüş
değeri
stut
size
ama
parametresi
int
my class'ın
double
açılımının
geri dönüş
değeri
stut
size
ama
parametresi
double
de
ara vereceğim
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
en çok karıştırılan
noktalardan
birine
bir değinelim
ondan sonra
kaldığımız yerden
geri
kaldığımız yere
geri dönelim
bu fonksiyonlar
kendisi
template mi
hayır
fonksiyonların
kendisi
template değil
ona ayrıca
değineceğim
oraya
baya bir
yolumuz var
ama
kısa cevabım
hayır
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
soru
bu koddaki
hata
nerede
cevap
my class
bir sınıf
değil
sınıf şablonu
sınıf olan
örneğin şu
peki
şimdi bakın
ve soruya cevap
vermeyiz
olsun
günün en önemli
sorularından biri
m1 ile m2'nin
türü
aynı mı
farklı mı
cevap
tabii ki
farklı
nedense
bu konuyla
ilk
danışanların
şöyle
bir
beklentisi
oluyor
aynı
sınıf
şablonundan
elde edilen
farklı
specialization'lar
tamamen
farklı
türler
yani
örneğin
a sınıfı
bir sınıf
b sınıfı
bir başka
sınıfı
olsaydı
nasıl
a ile b
farklı
sınıflarsa
arkadaşlar
bunlar da
farklı
sınıflar
biz kendimiz
örneğin
bir mekanizma
oluşturmazsak
şöyle bir
beklenti içinde
oluyor programcı
intten
double'a
dönüşüm
var mı
var
o zaman
diyor
m2 eşittir
m1 de
yazabilirim
hayır
bu iki
sınıf
birbirinden
tamamen
farklı
sınıflar
siz eğer
özel bir şekilde
dönüşüm
gerçekleştirecek
bir fonksiyon
bildirmediyseniz
ya da
tanımlamadıysanız
bunlar arasına
hiçbir şekilde
bir örtülü
dönüşüm yok
anlaşıldı
değil mi
aynı sınıf
şablonunun
farklı
specialization'ları
tamamen
farklı
türler
mesela
standart
tutuphaneden
örnek verelim
ondan sonra da
ara verelim
mesela şöyle
kodlar yazmaya
çalışıyorlar
diyor ki
arkadaşlar
iki tane
değişkeni var
bit setin
32 açılım
bu türünden
bs1
bit setin
16 açılım
bu türünden
bs2
bunlar
aynı sınıf
şablonunun
farklı
specialization'ı
olan sınıflar
aralarında
hiçbir şekilde
bir örtülü
dönüşüm yok
eğer tabi
kütfane kendisi
tanımlamadıysa
yani örneğin
bs1 eşittir
bs2
dediğinizde
arkadaşlar
sentars hatası
olması
normal
var
saat
21.07
21.25
de devam
edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
evet
aynı sınıf
şablondan
elde edilen
sınıflar
yani
farklı
specialization'lar
tamamen
farklı sınıflar
bunların
arasında
bir tür
dönüşümü
gerçekleştirecek
herhangi bir fonksiyon
olmadığı sürece
bunların arasında
bir dönüşüm
söz konusu
değil
arkadaşlar
ama biz önce bir
sentars tarafına
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar bu arada
bir arkadaşımın
şöyle bir sorusu
vardı
ona cevap
vermedim
fonksiyon
şablonlarıyla
ilgili
şöyle yapabilir
miyim
diyor
Boyd
Funk
diyelim ki
t türünden
x
burada
bu
fonksiyon
şablonunun
tanımı
ondan sonra
şu template
kısmını
tekrar etmeden
ikinci bir
fonksiyon
tanımlayabilir miyim
cevap
hayır
template
parametresi
de bir isim
template
parametrelerine
verilen
isimlerin
de bir
skopu var
dolayısıyla
şimdi
burada
template
parametresinin
isminin
skopunun
dışında
kullanmış
oluyorsunuz
dolayısıyla
bu
böyle bir
sentaks
geçerli
değil
arkadaşlar
sınıf
şablonlarında
normal
şablon
olmayan
jenerik
sınıflarda
olduğu gibi
sınıfın
sınıf şablonunun
bir
üye fonksiyonunu
sınıfın
içinde
inline
olarak
denilebilirsiniz
ya da
class
definition
dışında
tanımlayabilirsiniz
yani örneğin
burada
public
ya da
private
bir
üye fonksiyonu
olsun
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
t türünden
fonksiyonun
ismi
fu
olsun
parametresi
yine
t türünden
olsun
arkadaşlar
cons olmayan
bir üye fonksiyonu
olsun
bu fonksiyonun
tanımını
doğrudan
sınıf içinde
inline
olarak
yapabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
örneğin
kodu herhangi bir
anlamı
yüklemeyin
sadece
legal bir
yapı
oluşturuyorum
ya da
sınıfın
dışında
normal
sınıflarda
olduğu gibi
tanımlayabilirsiniz
ama sınıf dışında
tanımlamak
farklı kurallara
tabi
yine
arkadaşlar
hem de
keyword
olacak
ve
bu sınıf
bu fonksiyonun
tanımı
my class
sınıfının
p specialization
için
sonra
yine
fonksiyonun
ismini
parametrelerini
yazıyorsunuz
ve fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
türünü
yazıyorsunuz
fonksiyonun
tanımı
öyle yapılıyor
yani örneğin
burada
açısal parantezi
kullanmazsanız
syntax
geçerli
değil
arkadaşlar
bu arada
önemli
not
klasik
içinde
sınıf
şablonunun
ismini
doğrudan
specialization
ismi
olarak
kullanabilirsiniz
ne demek
istiyorum
mesela
şöyle bir
fonksiyon
olsaydı
ben
şöyle de
yazsam
arkadaşlar
şöyle de
yazsam
aynı anlamda
aşağıdaki
bar fonksiyonuna
bakın
açısal parantezi
hiç koymuyorum
şimdi
örneğin
my class'ın
int specialization
için
school fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
my class'ın
int açılımı
türünde
parametresi
my class'ın
int açılımı
türünde
ama
bar fonksiyonu
için de
böyle
yani
class definition
içinde
ya da
class scope
içinde
genel olarak
sınıf
şablonunun
ismini
kullanmak
ilgili
specialization'ı
kullanmak
demek
via fonksiyonu
için de
böyle
mesela
burada
diyelim ki
bir
yerel
değişken
olsaydı
my class
m
bu
my class'ın
int açılımı
için
bu yerel
değişkenin
türü
my class'ın
int specialization
double açılımı
için
bu sınıfın
türü
bu nesnenin
my class'ın
double açılımı
arkadaşlar
yani
sınıf
şablonunun
kendisinin
içinde
şablonun
ismini
kullanmak
aslında
bir
specialization'ı
kullanmak
demek
mesela
bakınız
bir örnek
verelim
typename
to
p
typename
u
volt
type
it
my class
m
typeid
name
bunu yazdırayım
stream başlık dosyasını dahil edelim
type info başlık dosyasını dahil edelim
so
see out
my class'ın
int virgül
long açılımı
x'in
u'su
bakın burada
my class demek
my class'ın
int
long açılımı
demek
my class'ın
int virgül
long açılımı
eğer
bu nesnenin türü
my class'ın
double virgül
şar açılımı
olsaydı
bu nesne de
aynı olacak
böyle yazmak
örneğin
şöyle yazmak
arasında
ikisini de bir göstereyim
bir fark yok
birinci de böyle
derleyip
çalıştıralım
arkadaşlar
ikinci de
sadece
my class'ı
kullanın
evet
takip edebildik mi
tamam
şimdi arkadaşlar
bir sınıf şablonunun
farklı specialization'ları
birer sınıf
dolayısıyla
bir sınıfı
kullanabildiğim her yerde
sınıf şablonunun
bir specialization'ı da
kullanabilirim
bunu yapabilir miyim
diye sormanıza
hiç gerek yok
arkadaşlar
mesela bakınız
şöyle bir şey
yapabilir miyim
my class'ın
int virgül
double açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
tanımladım
efendim
bunun adresini
arkadaşlar
özellikle
auto file deduction
kullanmıyorum
görün diye
bu türden
bir pointer
değişkende
sakladım
buna
bir referans
aldım
elven bir referans
gibi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
yani bu da
bildiğimiz
herhangi bir
sınıftan farkı yok
mesela
bir
fonksiyonun
parametresi
my class'ın
int virgül
int açılımı
türünden olabilir mi
olabilir
bu türden bir pointer
olabilir mi
olabilir
bu türden bir referans
olabilir mi
olabilir
yani böyle bir fonksiyonun
olmasında
hiçbir sakınca yok
yine fonksiyonun
örneğin geri dönüş
değeri türü
bu da bir sınıf
olduğuna göre
my class'ın
plot
virgül
double açılımı
olabilir mi
olabilir
yani normal bir sınıfı
kullandığım her yerde
bir sınıf şablonunun
bir specialization'ını
kullanabilirim
arkadaşlar
specialization'ın
kendisi bir
class olduğuna göre
bir başka
template de
template argümanı
olarak da
kullanılabilir
mesela
vektörün bir
template olduğunu
biliyorsunuz
değil mi
herkes biliyor
evet
şimdi
ben
vektörün
int açılımı
dediğimde
template argümanı
olarak
int törünü
kullanıyorum
ama
örneğin
vektörün
my class'ın
int virgül
double açılımı
dediğimde
bu sefer de
my class
sınıf şablonundan
instansiyat edilecek
duruma göre
my class'ın
int double
specialization'ı
vektör sınıfında
tür argümanı
oluyor
bu son derece
doğal
aynı sınıfı da
kullanabilirim
mesela şöyle bir şey
olabilir mi
my class'ın
int virgül
double açılımı
virgül
my class'ın
tabi böyle durumlar
için türeşlesin
bildirimi yapmak
çok daha iyi
long virgül
char
açılımı
my class
sınıf şablonu
iki tane
template argümanına
ihtiyacım var
bu da bir sınıf
olduğuna göre
bu sınıfı
birinci
template parametresine
karşılık gelen
template argümanı
olarak
bu sınıfı da
ikinci template
parametresine
karşılık gelen
template argümanı
olarak
kullanabilirim
bunları
eskiyen
konteynerlarında
yapabileceğimizi
göreceksiniz
mesela
aslında
vektör sınıf
şablonunun
birinci
template argümanı
vektörde tutulacak
ön'in türü
mesela vektör
int
bu
içinde int
tutan bir
dinamik dizi
e bu da
içinde
int vektör
tutan bir
dinamik dizi
yani
bu
specializationı
bu sefer de
yine aynı sınıf
şablonunda
template argümanı
olarak kullanıyorum
bunlarda
hiçbir problem
yok mesela
şöyle de olabilir
tabi bu tür
durumlarda
az önce söylediğim gibi
kodun daha kolay
okunması
anlaşılması için
süreç isim
bildirimi
yapmakta fayda var
dahası
fonksiyon
şablonları
ve type deduction
mekanizması
yine
az önceki
sınıf
şablonu
olsun
arkadaşlar
sadece bildirimini
gösteriyorum
mesela
bakınız
pamplet
type name
t
bold
bank
t
e şimdi ben
my class'ın
int virgül
double açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
oluştursam
pam
fonksiyonunu
tapımın için
incomplete type
olmaması
gerekiyor
şimdi
complete type
yapalım
evet
pam fonksiyonuna
m'yi argüman
olarak göndersem
derleyici template
argument
deduction'la
pam
fonksiyonunun
template parametresinin
bu tür olduğunun
çıkarımını yapacak
değil mi
bu da bir tür
burayı anladık mı
hatta hatta
çıkarım
böyle yapılmak
zorunda değil
mesela şöyle
olsaydı
my class'ın
arkadaşlar
t virgül
t açılımı
ya da
bunun kendisi de
bir
template
iki tane template
parametresine
sahip olsaydı
type name
u
my class'ın
t virgül
u açılımı
örneğin
böyle bir parametreye
sahip olsaydı
pank'ı şimdi
ben
m ile
çağırdığımda
fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeninin
türünün
my class'ın
int virgül
double açılımı
olması için
e'nin int
u'nun
double olması
gerekir
değil mi
bakın
bu da bir
deduction mekanizması
derleyici
17.
satırda yapılan
fank çaresi için
template argument
deduction yapacak
sonuçta parametrenin
my class'ın
int
double
specialization
türünden olması
için
template
parametreleri
olan
t ve u'nun
sırasıyla
int ve
double olması
gerekir
arkadaşlar
mesela
bakın çok
klasik örnekler
izleyin
benimki böyle bir sınıf var
bu sınıf türünden
iki tane nesneyi
bu sınıf
specialization
sonuçları
türünden
iki tane nesnenin
eşitlik karşılaştırmasını
yapacak
bir fonksiyonu
oluştursaydım
şöyle bir imkanım
olabilirdi
fonksiyonun
kendisini
arkadaşlar
bir
jenerik fonksiyonu
olarak
yazmadan
o zaman
şöyle bir şey
yazabilirdin
değil mi
mesela
bul
operatör küçük
myclass'ın
int açılımı
const
myclass
int
ref
const
myclass
int
ref
rehase
diyelim ki
kodun tamamını
yazmıyorum
arkadaşlar
sırasında
bir tane
pere elemanı var
şimdi
bunu da
public yapayım ki
bunu
access
kontrol ile ilgili
gibi görünmesin
t türünden
vay
ve şimdi
bakın
diyelim ki
fonksiyonun kodu
böyle oldu
return
lhs'nin
vali
eşit
arkadaşlar
rhs'nin
vali
şimdi bu fonksiyon
bir jenerik fonksiyon
değil
fonksiyonun
parametreleri
myclass
sınıfının
bu specialization
türünden
değil mi
ama şimdi
fonksiyonu şöyle yazsaydım
template type
int
const
myclass'ın
t açılımı
const
myclass'ın
t açılımı
şimdi artık
bu fonksiyon
şablondan
oluşturulacak
fonksiyonlar
myclass'ın
aynı
specialization
türünden
iki nesnenin
eşitlik
karşılaştırmasını
yapacak durumda
olacak
değil mi
örneğin
myclass'ın
int açılımı
türünden
x ve y
myclass'ın
double açılımı
türünden
arkadaşlar
d1 ve d2
şimdi ben
x küçüktür y
gibi ifade
yazdığımda
derleyici
buradan
t'yi
int olarak
alıp
bir fonksiyon
yazacak
ama
d1 küçüktür
d2 dediğim zaman
bu sefer de
t türü için
double'ı
template argümanı
olarak alacak
ve derleyicinin
yazdığı
fonksiyonun
parametreleri
cons myclass
double specialization'ı
double specialization
olacak
burada bütün
vurgu şuraya
değil mi
bir sınıf
şablonunun
bir specialization'ı
bir sınıftır
bir türdür
arkadaşlar
başka bir sınıf
şablonuna
template argümanı
olabilir
öyle değil mi
mesela
bakınız
bunun için
incomplete
type de olabilir
geçenlerde
bir arkadaşımın
sorusuydu
şimdi şöyle
olsaydı
class
match
arkadaşlar
class
match
mesela
michaels'ın
match
açılımı
burada
template argümanı
olan tür
match
henüz bir
incomplete
type
onun
complete
type olmasını
gerektiren bir
senaryo
olmadığı sürece
herhangi bir
problem
olmayacak
arkadaşlar
çağrılmayan
fonksiyonun
derleyici
kodunu da
yazmıyor
bunu daha önce
söylemiştim
diyelim ki
bu sınıfın
en tane fonksiyonu
olsa
void
bu
t
void
bar
t
bu redikat
void
baz
t
bakın
şimdi
diyelim ki
bu fonksiyonun
içinde
şöyle bir
kod
olsun
x'in
f'i
örneğe
dikkat
x'in
g'si
h'sı
fonksiyonlar
u
bar
ve bas
bak
sadece sınıf
şablonunun
kodunu
değerliyorum
herhangi bir
hata yok
değil mi
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
şimdi
bir sınıf
oluşturayım
struct
net
arkadaşlar
buna
p isimli
bir fonksiyon
koyayım
void
f
şimdi
bakınız
sınıfın
g isimli
bir fonksiyonu
var mı
sınıfın
h isimli
bir fonksiyonu
var mı
yok
sadece
f isimli
bir fonksiyonu
var değil mi
emira
evet
michael
has'ın
net açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
nesnenin
u fonksiyonu
çağır
arkadaşlar
evet
u fonksiyonu
bu fonksiyonu
t türünden
parametre istiyor
bir tane
nec nesnesi olsun
nec
my nec
argüman olarak
gönderelim
kodu
derliyorum
herhangi bir
sentars
hatası
var mı
burayı
anlamanız
önemli
sentars
hatası
yok
e
eğer
t türü
arkadaşlar
nec
türüyse
bu fonksiyonda
bar fonksiyonunun
parametresi de
nec
türünden
değil mi
o zaman
burada
nec
türünden
bir nesnenin
g fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
ama
g fonksiyonu
yok
anlaşıldı
değil mi
bu fonksiyon
çağrılmadığı
sürece
bu kod
yazılmayacak
ama
bakın şimdi
eğer ben
m'nin
var fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
şimdi
sentars
hatası
alacağım
çünkü
bunun kodu
yazılacak
gördünüz mü
aynı
şekilde
struct
nec
ergo
olsaydı
ertte
de
bir
g
isimli
fonksiyon
olsaydı
bu seferde
erk
türünden
bir nesnem
olsaydı
michael
has'ın
ergo
açılımı
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesnem
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
bakın
e'nin
bar fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
onda g
fonksiyonunu
çağırılıyor
değil mi
e'nin
buna
my
erk
mesnesini
argüman
olarak
göndersen
bu sefer
yine
sentars
kurası
olmayacak
yani
sınıfın
yani sınıfın
bütün
interface'inin
terket argümanına
uyumlu olması
gerekmiyor
onun kodu
çağrılmadığı
sürece
herhangi bir şekilde
bir kod
yazılmayacak
işte
string sınıfında
böyle olduğunu
düşünün
yani
onlarca
üye fonksiyon
hayır
runtime'da
yazılıyor
demek
değil
runtime'da
çağrılıyor
compile time'da
yazılıyor
derleyici
şimdi
bakınız
burada
derleyici
sadece
sınıfı
instant
şehit etti
fakat
sınıfın
constructor'ın
olsa olsa
default
constructor'ın
yazdırı
asıl
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
şurada
ama
burada
my
class'ın
neç
açılımı
için
full
fonksiyonunun
kodunu
yazdı
compile time'de
yazılıyor
ama
my
class'ın
neç
açılımının
bar
fonksiyonu
ve
bas
fonksiyonunun
kodu
yazılmadı
mesela
string sınıfı
için düşünün
arkadaşlar
düşünsenize
en güzel örnek
zaten
container
sınıflar
şimdi
şöyle
olsaydı
split
string
str
efendim
10 tane
a karakteri
derleyici
class
definition
yapacak
ama
hangi
fonksiyonun
kodunu
yazacak
dada
memberler için
değil
onlar
çünkü
class
definition
hangi
fonksiyonun
kodunu
yazacak
bu
constructor'ın
yani
fill
constructor'ın
bir de
destructor'ın
çünkü
destructor'ı da
çağrılıyor
ama
şimdi ben
size
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
seferde
derleyici
size fonksiyonunun
kodunu
yazacak
onlarca
daha
string
sınıfının
üye fonksiyonu
var
onların
kurdu
yazılmak zorunda
değil
anladınız
değil mi
evet
yani
sınıf şablonlarının
önemli bir
faydası da
bu
değerli arkadaşlar
devam edelim
sınıf şablonlarına
biraz daha
sentaksına bakalım
klas
tablet
like
name
klas
my
public
old
bank
t
arkadaşlar şimdi bakın
çok mürakatlarda da
üretimde de
önemli
bir
konuya
değineceğim
oraya çok dikkatli
izleyin
benim arkadaşım
şöyle bir soru
sordu
dedi ki
bunun kendisi
bir
sınıf
bunun kendisi
bir şablon
mu
sınıfın
kendisi
şablon
ama
fan fonksiyonunun
kendisi
bir template
değil
yani bu ne
demek
biz derleyiciye
type parametresi
karşılığı
kullanılacak
template
argümanının
int
olduğunu
söylersek
derleyicinin
yazdığı
fonksiyonun
parametresi
int
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
bakınız
şimdi ben
my klas'ın
int açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
oluştursam
x'in
fan fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yapsam
x'in
fan fonksiyonunun
parametresinin
int türü
olmama
ihtimali
var mı
örneğin
derleyici
buradan
parametresi
double olan
bir fonksiyon
yazabilir mi
cevap
hayır
burayı anlamak
önemli
anlaşıldı
değil mi
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
int
yani burada
bir çıkarım
mekanizması
yok
zaten
parametre
int
mesela
bu programcılara
mülakatlarda
en çok
sorulan
sorulardan
biri
şu
diyor ki
bu
forwarding
parametre mi
universal
reference
parametre mi
değil mi
cevap
tabi ki
değil
yani
eğer
universal
parametre
olsaydı
universal
reference
parametre
olsaydı
her türlü
argümanı
kabul ederdi
değil mi
o zaman
bakınız
fang fonksiyonu
kullanmasak da
derleyici tarafından
yazılmış olacak
değil mi
hayır
fang fonksiyonu
kullanmazsak
tanımı
derleyici tarafından
yapılmayacak
önce
burayı
bir
anlayın
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonun
parametresi
için bir
çıkarım
yapılıyor
mu
hayır
bu
universal
reference
mı
hayır
sağ taraf
referans
bu soruyu
çok soruyorlar
ve genelde de
hemen herkes buna
universal reference
diyor
ref refi
gördüğü için
oysa bakın
mesela
michaelers'ın
int açılımı
türünden
x
arkadaşlar
fang
int
fil
meriç turşan
hocam peki
nereye yazıyor
bu kodları
onu da konuşacağız
meriç
işte o
nereye yazıyor
bu kodları
dediğimiz
bu şekilde
sorduğumuz
soru
hangi konuyla
ilgili
önce onu
iyi anlamak
gerekiyor
template
instantiation
ile ilgili
orayı
mercek altına
aldığımızda
konuşmamız
lazım
ama önce
şunu görmenizi
istiyorum
x
fang
y
bir şey
dikkatinizi
çekiyor mu
santax hatası
neden
çünkü
michaelers'ın
int açılımının
pump fonksiyonunun
parametresi
t template
parametresine karşılık
gelen
template
argümanı
int olduğuna
göre
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
int
refer
yani bu
ne
değil
kesinlikle
universal
reference
değil
bravo
rasul
fonksiyonun
parametresi
r value
referansı
olmasına rağmen
l value
gönderdiğim için
santax hatası
olacak
emirhan
çelik
intrefref
üniversal
değil mi
değil
hayır
o sağ taraf
referansı
arkadaşlar
oraya da
bir gönderme
yapalım
oraya
emirhan
atlamış
olabilirsiniz
bakınız
çok dikkatli
izleyin
universal
reference
olması
için
template
parametresinin
doğrudan
fonksiyonun
parametresinde
ref ref
dek
narratörüyle
birlikte
olması
lazım
şimdi
soru
buradaki
parametre
universal
reference
parametre
mi
cevap
evet
şimdi
sorulara
devam
ediyorum
dikkatli izleyin
buradaki
universal
reference
parametre
mi
cevap
hayır
kesinlikle
değil
arkadaşlar
bu
const
r value
reference
parametre
yani
buraya
const
volatile
herhangi bir
specifier
koyarsanız
artık
universal
reference
parametre
değil
soru
class
bunlar da
mülakatların
en çok
sorulan
soruları
mesela
bakınız
class
template
type name
class
my class
t açılımı
ref ref
bu fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
parametresi
universal
reference
mı
cevap
hayır
sadece t
ref ref
olduğunda
universal
referans
burayı
anladık mı
mesela
standart
kütüphanenin
vektör
templateini
düşünün
bunlar
üretimde
çok sık
karşımıza
çıkacak
bunu ne
zannediyor
programcı
sanki bu
universal
reference
vektör
t
ref
hayır
alakası
yok
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
her zaman
vektörün
falanca
specialization
türünden
r value
referans
parametre
buraya kadar
emiran
anladık mı
şimdi sizin
sorunuzun
cevabına
geleceğim
soru
emiran
şimdi soruya
cevap
vermeye
çalışın
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
universal
reference
mı
yoksa
sağ taraf
referans
mı
bir
deduction
olmadığına
göre
r value
referans
değil mi
gidip de buna
universal
referans
deyip
der miyiz
mesela bu
fonksiyonu
r value
ile karamazsınız
değil mi
evet
şimdi
söyleyin
my class'ın
int açılını
için
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
int ref ref
değil mi
burada bir
çıkarım yok ki
burayı
anladık mı
my class'ın
int açılını
için
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
int ref ref
yani bu universal
referans
değil
şimdi
daha iyi anlayacaksınız
merak etmeyin
sadece çok dikkatli
izlemenizi istiyorum
biraz kafanız
karışacak
mesela
izleyin
bu
burada bir
full fonksiyonu
olsaydı
full fonksiyonun
parametresi
arkadaşlar
my class
türünden
olsaydı
ve ben
ben şimdi
my class'ın
int açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
tanımlasaydım
ve
izleyin
my class'ın
bir de
double açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
tanımlasaydım
buna x
diyelim
buna y
soru
y'nin
full fonksiyonuna
x'e
argüman olarak
gönderebilir miyim
cevap
hayır
çünkü
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
arkadaşlar
my class'ın
double açılımı
ama ben
my class'ın
int açılımı
başka bir sınıf
türünden nesne
gönderiyorum
değil mi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şimdi
o zaman
şöyle bir soru
sorulabilir
en çok
karıştırılan
konulardan biri
bir sınıfın
arkadaşlar
üye fonksiyonu
bir sınıf
şablonunun
kendisi de
bir template
olabilir mi
senin
arkadaşlarından
biri template
mi diye
sordu ya
olabilir
ama onun
sentaksı
farklı
şimdi
aradaki
farka
bakın
boy
arkadaşlar
fu
p
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
my class'ın
int açılımı
için
int
my class'ın
double açılımı
için
double
değil mi
mesela
şöyle bir
kod yazsam
elimde bir
string nesnesi
var
string
str
ve ben
my class'ın
int açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
tanımlasam
bunun
fu
fonksiyonuna
gidip de
string'i
gönderebilir
miyim
cevap
hayır
çünkü
sentaks
hatası
olur
neden
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
int
dolayısıyla
int parametre
string gönderiyorum
böyle bir
örtülü
dönüşüm de
yok
ama
şimdi
izleyin
bu fonksiyon
şöyle
olsaydı
template
type name
u
bakın
ayrı bir
isim
kullanmalıyım
void
fu
u
şimdi artık
bu
kesinlikle bir
fonksiyon
şablonu
yani
my class'ın
herhangi bir
specialization
için
herhangi bir
parametreye
sahip
fu
fonksiyonu
yazılabilir
demek bu
anlaşıldı mı
çağrı oraya
geleceğim
yani
otoyu
kullanabilirim
kesinlikle
evet
şimdi
mesela
bakınız
my class
m
my class'ın
int açılımı
m
ama
m.fu
efendim
string
herhangi bir
syntax hatası
olmadığını
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
şimdi
dahası
izleyin
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
my class'ın
u açılımı
olsaydı
şimdi artık
arkadaşlar
my class'ın
herhangi bir
açılımı
nesnesi için
ona
my class
sınıfının
herhangi bir
specialization'ı
türünden
argüman
gönderebiliyor
olacaktım
bakın
demin legal
olmayan yapı
şimdi legal
olacak
my class'ın
int açılımı
x
my class'ın
double açılımı
y
aradaki farka
bakın
x'in
u fonksiyonuna
y
argümanı
olarak gönderdim
bunun hiçbir
syntax hatası
yok
ve şimdi bir şey
görmenizi istiyorum
arkadaşlar
dikkat edin
bu fonksiyon
içinde
bakalım
soruma cevap
vermeye çalışın
bu fonksiyon içinde
yıldız disin
türü ne
aşağıdaki
çağrıdan bahsediyorum
yıldız disin
türü ne
cevap
my class'ın
int
açılımı
çok güzel
peki
fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeninin
türü ne
arkadaşlar
cevap
my class'ın
double açılımı
onu gösterelim isterseniz
pipe info başlık taslası
dahil edilmiş durumda
pipe id
arkadaşlar
yıldız dis
name
bu demek ki nokta operatörünün sol operanda olan sınıf nesnesinin türü
see out
hemen altına
pipe id
t'nin neyini
benim derleyicim zaten çok güzel bir string veriyor
arkadaşlar bakın biri
my class'ın int açılımı
diğeri
my class'ın double açılımı
mesela
bunun çok tipik bir örneğini
standart kütüphanenin
pair sınıfında
ondan sonraki dersimizin
konu açıklarından biri olacak
pair sınıfında göreceksiniz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
sınıf şablonuna
duyulacak
ihtiyacı
belki de
en güzel gösteren
en basit örneği
standart kütüphanemizin
utility
başlık dosyası içinde
tanımlanan
tut pair
arkadaşlar
o kadar çok yer var ki
mutlaka böyle yerlerde
C'de de
C++'da dokunuluyorsan
arkadaşlarım karşılaşmıştır
iki tane türü
Emrah'ım birazdan
sorunuza cevap vereceğim
iki tane türü
birlikte
paketlemek istiyorsunuz
ama bunların ortak
böyle bir
interfejste
olmayacak
mesela bir fonksiyondan
iki tane değer döndürmek için
şimdi CEO olsaydı
şöyle bir şey yapabilirdim
değil mi
diyelim ki
böyle bir
yapı türü
oluşturayım
buna
iki tane türden
eleman koyayım
ki bu
C++'da da
bazı yerlerde
kullanılıyor
şimdi bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
türünü
data türü yaparsam
aslında fonksiyonun
data türünden
bir değer döndürmesi
demek
bir int
bir double döndürmesi
demek
ama şimdi
düşünün
bir arada
tabiri caizse
paketleyeceğim
bundle edeceğim
iki tane ayrı
değer
sonsuz sayıda
türlerden
seçilebilir
değil mi
mesela
int ile double
double ile long
my class da
fighter sınıfı
net sınıfı ile
er sınıfı gibi
o zaman
onlarca
yüzlerce
farklı sınıf
yazmak yerine
tabii ki
bir sınıf
şablonu
oluşturmayı
tercih edebilirim
değil mi
tercih ederim
gerçekten de
çok basitleştirmiş
olarak gösteriyorum
çünkü
bilmediğimiz
henüz
bir sürü
jenerik programlama
öğesi kullanıyor
şimdi şöyle bir tür
olduğunu düşünün
type name t
type name u
class
pair
pair'in kendisi
bir sınıf
arkadaşlar
şimdi izleyin
bunun iki tane
öğesi olsa
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
birinci öğesi
t türünden
first ismini
alsın
ikinci öğesi
u türünden
second ismini
alsın
şimdi
stack pair'in
int virgül
double
açılımının
first isimli
elemanı
int
second isimli
elemanı
double
o zaman
örneğin
bir fonksiyonun
ben
bir int
bir double
döndürmesini
istersem
pair'in
int
double
açılımı
türünden
geri dönüş
değeri
olmasını
sağlarım
değil mi
mesela böyle bir fonksiyon
bu türden
bir nesne döndürüyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama baka şimdi
birazdan standart
tütfarenin
pair template'ini
göstereceğim
şimdi
sınıf sadece
bu kadarla
kalsaydı
benim
yukarıdaki
pair template'inin
double
açılımı
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesneye
buna
pd
diyelim
şunu atayabilir miydim
int
arkadaşlar
bunu atayabilir miydim
cevap
hayır bunlar ayrı sınıflar
pd
eşittir
santart
hatası olurdu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ama şimdi
bakın
bu sınıfın
şöyle bir
konstruktörü
olsaydı
template
arkadaşlar
type name
x
u
herkes
y özür dilerim
farklı isim
kullanacak
bu artık
bir member template
oluyor değil mi
mesela
böyle bir
konstruktör
olsaydı
pair'in
arkadaşlar
const
pair'in
x
virgül
y açılımı
türünden
referans
şimdi
bakın
ve soruma cevap
vermeye çalışın
o zaman
böyle bir
konstruktör ile
ben
herhangi bir
pair
specialization
ile
pair'in
başka bir
specialization
ile
başlatabilirdim
doğru mu
arkadaşlar
bu arada
tane
default
konstruktör
olsun ki
aşağıdaki
kod
syntax
hatası
olmasın
bakın
şimdi
kodu
değerliyorum
ve bir
syntax
hatası
yok
neden
çünkü bu
member template
yani
şimdi ben
pair'in
herhangi bir
specialization
türünden
bir nesneyi
neyle
başlatabilirim
pair'in
başka bir
specialization
türünden
nesneyiyle
başlatabilirim
aradaki
farkı
gördük mü
evet
arkadaşlar
bakınız şimdi
çok dikkatli
izliyorsunuz
orijinali de
böyle
şimdi
gerçek
str'deki
pair
utility'deki
sınıfına
bakalım
arkadaşlar
mesela
pair'in
string
biraz da
karmaşık
hale getireyim
pair'in
string
double
açılımı
pair'in
once
char
yıldız
int
açılımı
bunlar
farklı
iki sınıf
türünden
nesne
ama
px
eşittir
py
dediğimde
arkadaşlar
bir
syntax
hatası
olmamasının
nedeni
o
constructor'ın
member
template
olması
member
template
konusu
önemli
şimdi
daha önceki
soruya
geri dönelim
şu
universal
reference
mı
değil
tekrar
oraya
geri dönelim
şöyle
bir
template
olsaydı
type
name
t
class
mark
public
void
fu
href
ref
bu
universal
reference
parametre
değil
ama
bakın
şöyle
olsaydı
template
type
name
u
void
fu
u
ref
artık
universal
reference
parametri
için
bütün
kotalları
sağlıyor
bu artık
universal
reference
parametri
yani bu
ne demek
şimdi
michael
hos'un
fu
fonksiyonu
herhangi
türden
const
ya da
non
const
bir argüman
alabilir
bütün
argümanları
kabul eder
öyle
değil mi
evet
buradaki
type
deduction
kurallarını
öğrenmiştik
değil mi
aynı kurallar
burada da
geçerli
isterseniz
bakın
michael hos'un
int açılımı
türünden
x
arkadaşlar
x'in
u'su
bu
r
value
value
herhangi bir şekilde
bir
syntax
hatası
oldu
mu
hayır
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
efendim
bu
const
el
value
consta da
kabul ediyor
çünkü bu
fonksiyonun
parametresi
universal
reference
aradaki farkı
anladık sanıyorum
evet
mesela bakınız
standart kütüphaneden bir örnek verelim
arkadaşlar
izleyin
vektörün
int açılımı türünden
vek
vekin
pushback'i
arkadaşlar bir şey dikkatinizi çekiyor mu
derleyici gösterirken doğrudan parametreyi int ref ref diyor
görüyorsunuz değil mi
evet
peki bu nasıl bir fonksiyon
parametresi
r
value
referansı olan bir fonksiyon
bu fonksiyona sadece ve sadece ne gönderebilirim
intürden bir r
value gönderebilirim
oysa diğer overload
görüyorsunuz
constel value referans
şimdi vektör sınıfını düşünün
ve pushback'in az önce bahsettiğimiz yapıya tamamen uyduğunu düşünün
basit değiştirmiş olarak gösteriyorum
template type name'de
class
vektör
bakın şimdi
public
iki tane pushback fonksiyonu var
void
pushback
const
ref
void pushback
ref ref
ne diyor bu konuyu daha önce anlatmıştım
l value'lar bana gelsin
r value'lar bana gelsin
diyor
bu vektörde t türünden nesneyi oluşturmak için
vektörün copy konstruktörünü kullanıyor
bu ise vektörün diyorum t sınıfının copy konstruktörünü kullanıyor
bu ise move konstruktörünü kullanacak
soru
bu fonksiyonun parametresi
r value referans mı
universal referans mı
cevap tabii ki
r value referans
mesela ben
vektörün int açılımı sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne için pushback'i çağırsam
arkadaşlar
eğer bu olmasaydı
buna l value gönderseydim
syntax hatası olacaktı değil mi
ama şimdi bakın
arkadaşlar
hatta içine yazalım
cout
l value
arc
buraya da şöyle yazalım
cout
r value arc
şimdi bakın
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
pushback
hangisi çağrılacak
arkadaşlar
r value olduğu için
atlaki çağrılacak değil mi
ama
int x
pushback
x
l value
görüyor musunuz
mesela
bu
l value
overloadu
olmasaydı
arkadaşlar
e
sadece
r value referans
parametreli olduğu için
32. satırdaki
çağrı
syntax hatası
olacaktı
pushback
böyle mesela
ama
diğer taraftan
izleyin
ileride göreceğimiz
emplace fonksiyonları
onlar bambaşka
şimdi bakın
template type name
u
void
u ref ref
artık şimdi
bu fonksiyona
ne gönderebilirim
herhangi türden
bir argüman gönderebilirim
değil mi
isterseniz
isterseniz bakın
ivek'in
u'su
l value olan
x'i de
alacak
r value olan
5'i de
4'ü de
alacak
efendim
const
l value olan
yine
cx'i de
olacak
hiçbiri ne
değil
syntax hatası
arkadaşlar
bu
sınıf şablonunun
template argümanlarına
bakın şimdi
biraz da bunun
esprisini
yapalım
mesela
template type name
t
plus
my class
herhangi bir fonksiyon
word for
cout
pipe id
yield
doğrudan şöyle de
yazabilirim
pipe id
yıldız
is
name
şimdi
bakın
my class'ın
int açılımı
ve
x kaldı mı
evet
mey'nin
full fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
arkadaşlar
private olduğu için
syntax hatası
oldu
terliyorum
evet
bakın
arkadaşlar
sınıf
my class
my class'ın
class my class'ın
int açılımı
arkadaşlar
yani
burada
template argümanı
olarak kullanılan
bu tür
yine bu
template'ten
oluşturuldu
bu tür
yine bu
template'ten
oluşturuldu
bakın
şimdi
buna
çok güzel bir örnek
vereceğim size
çok dikkatli izleyin
harika bir örnekle
karşılaşacaksınız
şimdi
esleyelim
pair template'i
o kadar çok yerde
karşımıza çıkacak ki
şöyle bir
template
önce çok basit
bir üstünden
geçelim
başlık dosyası
utility
ama birçok
standart
başlık dosyası
utility'yi
include
ediyor
arkadaşlar
iki tane
template
parametresi var
örneğin
şimdilik
gözling
direktifini
kullanıyorum
pair'in
int
double açılımı
arkadaşlar
çok
öğrenmek için
ideal bir
sınıf
sınıf'in
genelik programlamanın
neredeyse
bütün araçlarımı
kullanıyor
bizim şimdiye
kadar konuştuğumuz
ya da konuşmadığımız
mesela
default
constructor
sınıf'ın
first
ve
second
isimli
elemanlarını
ki
first'ün
türü
birinci
template
argümanı
second'ün
türü
ikinci
template
argümanı
value
initialize
ediyor
value
initialization
konusunu
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
aritmetik
türden
nesneler
value
initialize
edildiğinde
değerleri
ne
oluyordu
sıfır
pointer'lar
null pointer
booleum
false oluyordu
değil mi
dolayısıyla
ben şimdi
p1'in
first elemanına
erişsem
bu normal bir
structure
ve
arkadaşlar
p2'nin
p1'in
second elemanına
erişsem
bunların
değeri
sıfır
yani
default
construct edilmiş
bir
pair
nesnesinin
arkadaşlar
first of
and second
value
initialize
ediliyor
tabi ki
bunlar
bir sınıf
türünden
olsaydı
onların
value
initialize
edilmesi
demek
default
constructor'larının
çağrılması
demek
mesela
söyleyin
bakalım
pair'in
string
açılımı
olsaydı
first'ü
de
second'ı
da
arkadaşlar
default
construct edilmiş
bir
pointer
türünler
olsaydı
non
ptr
mi
de
evet
emirat
kesinlikle
şimdi
bakın
p'nin
first'ünün
length'i
p'nin
second'ının
length'i
bunlar
default
construct edildiği
için
arkadaşlar
uzunluk
değerleri
sıfır
çünkü
boy
string
desteleri
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
ama şimdi
bakın
pair'in
int
double
açılımı
türünden
p
parametreli
constructları
da var
birinci
parametresi
t türünden
ikinci
parametresi
u türünden
yani
örneğin
şöyle yazsaydım
arkadaşlar
first'ünü
12 yapmış
olacaktım
second'ını
yani
double türden olan
second'ını
56 yapmış
olacaktım
takip edebiliyor muyuz
isterseniz yazdıralım
c out
p'nin
first'ü
bu arada
en iyi bilmeniz
gereken sınıflardan
biri
ben şimdi
çok yüzeysel
dokunuyorum
yavaş yavaş
yavaş
deneyen
günlerde
bu
acl'in
en önemli
sınıf şablonlarından
biri olan
pair sınıfını
bu kadar çok yerde
karşımıza çıkacak ki
çok iyi öğreneceğiz
p'nin
second'ı
p'nin first'ü
p'nin
second'ı
şimdi
çok dikkatli izleyin
pair sınıf şablonu
için bir
insörter yok
buraya dikkat
yani insörter
demekle
neyi kastettiğimi
biliyorsunuz
değil mi
bir çıkış akımına
yazdıracak
bir
doğrudan
standart
kütüphanenin
verdiği bir
utility yok
yani örneğin
şöyle yazsam
c out
p
böyle bir
insörter olmadığı
için
syntax hatası
olacak
neden
syntax hatası
olduğunu
anladık
değil mi
bunu yazdıracak
bir fonksiyon
yok
mesela
ben şimdi
parametresi
pair'in
int double
açılımı
türünden
olan
bir
operator
left
shift
fonksiyonu
yazsaydım
bu legal
olurdu
değil mi
ama
şimdi bakın
ne yapacağız
herkes çok
dikkatli
izliyor
bu
insörter'ın
kendisinde
bir fonksiyon
şablonu
olarak
yazalım
ve derleyici
bu fonksiyon
şablonunda
her pair
için
bir tane
ayrı fonksiyon
yazabilsin
o zaman
şöyle bir fonksiyon
yazsam
bakın
daha önce
öğrendiklerimizle
biraz
birleştireceğiz
template
type name
t
u
bu tür
fonksiyonların
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
ne oluyordu
stut
o stream
referans
fonksiyon
operator
left
shift
birinci
parametresi
stut
o stream
referans
arkadaşlar
ikinci
parametresi
buraya
dikkat
stut
pair
in
t virgül
u açılımı
türünden
const
referans
anlamadığımız
bir yer
olduğunda
doğrudan
tekrar etmemi
isteyin
şimdi bakın
böyle bir fonksiyon
varsa
gördünüz
değil mi
bu da legal
arkadaşlar
hadi buna
p1
diyelim
buna p2
efendim
istediğiniz
farklı türden
fonksiyonu
yazın
mesela bu
int int olsun
p3
diyelim
bakın
siyahat
p1
p2
p3
hepsinin
legal olduğunu
göreceksiniz
çünkü
derleyici bu
fonksiyon
şablonundan
her farklı
pair
türü için
aynı
bir fonksiyon
yazabilir
değil mi
ama şimdi
sizi şaşırtacağım
biraz
izleyin
fonksiyonun
gerçekten
kodunu
yazalım
yalnız
bir dakika
burada şunu
anladık
değil mi
bunların
buradan kodun
yazılabilmesi
için
tabi ki
t'nin ve
u'nun
bir streame
insertable
olması lazım
kodu çünkü
şöyle yazacağım
os
herkes dikkatli
izliyor
iyi ayırt edin diye
köşeli parantez
içine yazacağım
t'nin first'ü
araya bir virgül
koyacağım
arkadaşlar
t'nin second'ü
sonra da
tapanan köşeli parantez
yani köşeli parantez
kullanmamın nedeni
sizin
diğer öğelerden
ayırt etmenizi
sağlamak
return
şimdi bakın
mesela p1'i
yazdırsam
new line
derleyici burada
ikinci parametresi
pair'in
ink double
açılımı olan
bir fonksiyon
yazacak
değil mi
gördük mü
evet
şimdi bakın
arkadaşlar
ama bu
pair'in
ink double
açılımı
değil de
pair'in
string double
açılımı
olsaydı
yine bir
syntax hatası
olmayacak
ama bakın
syntax hatası
olmamasının
nedeni
string sınıfının
da
insertable
olması
değil mi
mesela
mesela şöyle
olsaydı
plus
neco
ve
pair'in
neco
virgül
double
açılımı
olsaydı
şimdi
neden
syntax hatası
olacak
söyleyin
çünkü
pair'in
first'ü
neco
türünden
ama neco
bir nesneyi
yazdırmak
için
bir
insörter
fonksiyonu yok
değil mi
arkadaşlar takip edebiliyor muyuz
syntax hatası
ol
biraz sabırlı olun
bir iki dakika
geç
çıkabiliriz
ama şimdi
size bir sürprizim
var
burayı anladınız
değil mi
peki
pair'in
arkadaşlar
int açılımı
türünden
int
double açılımı
türünden
P1
7.4
şimdi
izleyin
pair'in
arkadaşlar
int double açılımı
türünden
takip edebiliyor muyuz
virgül
pair'in
örneğin
string
long açılımı
türünden
bu nasıl bir tür oldu
birinci template
argümanı
parametresi için
pair'in bir specialization
kullandım
ama ikinci template
parametresi için de
pair'in bir specialization
kullandım
şimdi bunu
initialize edelim
ismi P olsun
arkadaşlar
mesela
3.4
pair
bütün bu konuları
anlatacağım
Murat
L
verliyorum
bir
santaks hatası yok
bakın şimdi
şurada
santaks hatası
olacak mı
Cout
P
şablonların
general programlamanın
güzelliğini gösteren
çok basit bir örnek
derleyici
yukarıdaki
templetten
önce
bu
pair
sınıfı için
bir kod
yazacak
burada
template
parametresi
arkadaşlar
aslında bu
pair türünden
fakat
bunu yazarken
first'ü yazdırırken
first'ü de
bu türden olduğu için
bunun içinde bir
fonksiyon yazacak
bu da başka bir tür
olduğu için
bunun içinde bir fonksiyon
yazacak
anladınız değil mi
toplam 3 tane fonksiyon
yazacak
ama sizde zaten bunu
fonksiyonların
yazım biçiminden
göreceksiniz
bakınız
aslında
köşeli parantez içinde
12.3.4'ü
yazdıran
o
fonksiyon
şablonunun
bir specialization'ı
şunu yazdıran
başka bir specialization'ı
dıştaki
köşeli parantezi
yazdıran
başka bir specialization'ı
espriyi
anladınız mı
burada yazılan
fonksiyon
pair'in
int double açılımı
buradaki
pair'in
string
int
long açılımı
ama
en dıştakini
yazdıran
pair'in
falanca
filanca
açılımı
evet bugün
sınıf şablonlarına
bir giriş yaptık
sadece bir giriş yaptık
ama yavaş yavaş
işin içine gireceğiz
ne kadar güçlü
bir araç olduğunu
C++
dilinin
gücünün
aslında önemli
kısmının
generic programlama
paradigmasından
geldiğini
yavaş yavaş
göreceksiniz
burada
sadece biraz
sabırlı olmanız
gerekiyor
çok fazla
araç var
birbirine
benziyor
terimler
birbirine yakın
her standartla
yeni özellikler
geliyor
yani bir kere de
böyle ben anlatayım
siz dinleyin
hemen bunu
üretimde kullanmanız
çok kolay olmayabilir
ama yavaş yavaş
yavaş yavaş
kod yazdıkça
kod okudukça
bunlar yerine
oturacak
hiç merak etmeyin
peki
arkadaşlar
çarşamba
günkü dersimizde
tekrar görüşmek üzere
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
ve herkese
iyi akşamlar diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone olmayı
abone ol